so we'll be going live in three two and
one
okay ladies and gentlemen good evening
you've only just come back for one and
you're being a troublemaker already stop
it ladies and gentlemen we are we are
now live it is 6 p.m so um if I could
have your attention for the meeting
um my name is Peter Richards
I'm getting feedback sorry my name is
Peter riches and I will be chairing
tonight's planning committee meeting
um it is a meeting in public not a
public meeting so please only those
people that are registered to speak will
be permitted to do so at the appropriate
time I will call you forward to one of
the three desks in front of you
um and and you'll have your lot of time
I'll let you know what your time is then
um when you sit down if you uh press the
button in the middle of the microphone
it will go red and you will be able to
be uh you'll be able to speak and you'll
be heard and then again if you could uh
press it to turn it off when you're done
that would be great and if you could
remain seated for questions that would
be also very helpful
um we're not expecting any fire alarms
so if one does go off please follow us
in an orderly fashion across to the car
park over the road we will need you to
stay there so we can check all your
names off and make sure everyone has got
it safely out of the building before we
send you on your Merry Little way
um mobile phones if you could please
turn them to silent uh off is preferable
but silent at the very least I
appreciate people sometimes need to use
them feel free to do so provided it
doesn't uh conflict with the the proper
procedures of of the committee and and
put us off what we're trying to do okay
um and we are of course being recorded
and live streamed uh as we speak um for
for later viewing
Amy Shipley who is our solicitor
and in no particular order our planners
asked
because an expert on on certain items
um and our planning manager who um
unfortunately contracted covert uh last
night I think um is joining us online
our planner manager is Alice cosnet
Alice I think you've probably got
something you'd like to say a statement
to make
yes thank you Council I just want to
check you can hear me
yes we can perfect thank you so my role
is to provide impartial advice and to
assist members in their decision taking
thank you
thank you very much right let's move
into the full agenda um so first of all
apologies for absence please
we have apologies from councilor
Jennings for whom councilor Harvey is
substituting Council a rock for whom
counselor Adam is substituting councilor
Mills for whom councilor Cargill is
substituting and Council seraphin for
whom cancer of wolf is substituting
marvelous thank you very much and
Welcome to our substitutes
um discloses of Interest members do we
have any disclosures please below me
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go around if I
may so cancel Kendall's first of all
please thank you it's a personal
non-punery um
disclosure of interest uh the uh
applicant for item number six King
Edward school is known to me I taught
his daughter a few years ago there we go
thank you very much Council Parry uh
thank you and good evening chair
um I wish to advise my interest in the
um planning application 22 forward slash
00748 forward slash very I am personally
known to the neighbors of the
um application in question I presume
you'll be withdrawing from the item I
shall be withdrawing from the committee
stepping down thank you understood thank
you very much Council cargo thank you
chair um due to a late substitution I
was unable to attend the uh organized
site visits but I have been uh to
marriage Hill and bulletin prize to see
the sites from myself marvelous thank
you very much Council Adam
uh similarly I wasn't able to attend the
site business
thank you very much uh Council Rolfe
uh thank you chair
um
I am the ward member for application
2104.006 full the cares application uh I
will step down because I will be
speaking uh on this application so I
will walk away from this seat thank you
Mr Marvin thank you Council Harvey I'm
in the same position as
um Council Cargill I wasn't able to
attend the organized site visit that I
have independently visited sites in
relation to Applications four five and
seven thank you very much uh councilor
Curtis
thank you yes just to say uh application
22 01984 slash Ludington Road
um I am the ward member for shotry
Darlington Road that's in my ward
um but I've had no
um contact with the applicant a process
with a completely open mind I'm happy to
stay in the meeting for that if that's
except to watch it if you're here with
that in mind which you said you are then
yes that's absolutely fine uh councilor
Adam again forgive me I forgot to
imagine I'm the ward member for item
number five on the agenda and so I'll be
stepping down speaking on that no
problem thank you very much anyone else
before I give mine no okay so uh on uh
application reference
2104006 ful that's King Edwards school
um I used to coach Cricket on that site
um I haven't done for 10 years
um so I just think it's important to
make that known clearly I'm here with no
mind
um so I will stay on the uh agenda on
the um on the committee for that
um and it has become current today that
on application
2200748 vary that is the land of bamboo
Road in Pillars and priors
um it turns out that uh I am a member of
the same Club as one of the neighbors I
also it turns out I'm on the same
WhatsApp as one of the neighbors however
we've never spoken we've until today
until we met inside today I'm here with
a completely open mind and will remain
on uh on the committee for that um I
have sought legal advice on that and
that has been confirmed as acceptable
okay let's move on to our minutes is
everyone happy with the minutes are set
out in the agenda a quick show of hand
so it looks like there's lots of nods
yet I think that's agreed marvelous
let's move to our first item then which
is application reference
2201071 ful as a land north of marriage
Hill in bidford at Pon Avon our
presenting officer
have I got that the right way around yes
presenting a shirt floaters here that's
not your name on here
Stuart over here
thank you chairman good evening
everybody
um this proposal is taking planning
permission for the direction of three
dwellings and Associated development uh
the proposal involves the demolition of
three barns that currently occupy the
site
um here we see the approximate location
of the site uh signified by the black
dot
um to the north of the b439 uh the
application site is within the adopted
buildsbury boundary of bidford and Haven
with areas of open Countryside to the
north and west
here we see the proposed site layout
plan illustrating the three dwellings
this plan here shows the point of
vehicle access
um that is to be used this is an
existing access track there is an area
shaded in purple here where there is
proposed to be widened to help
accommodate vehicle access
here we have some indicative visuals of
the pose development
here we see the proposed elevational
detail for plots one and two
and again here we see the proposed
elevations for plot number three
um here we see the proposed Works to the
point of access to include widening uh
it's a little bit larger here in the
area shaded purple and the proposed bin
collection points signified here
we now have some photos of the site and
its surroundings
um here we are stood on the existing
access track looking southwards back
towards the b439 one can see uh to the
left there are the back of some of the
neighboring properties off Harbor close
here we are stood in the crude center of
the application site looking southwards
uh one can see there are two barns here
to the left and right that are proposed
to be demolished as part of this
proposal
um and again here we see one of the
barns in Greater detail
um looking North westwards one can also
see that there is ways of open
Countryside to the north and west of the
site
um here we are stood outside the
application site looking eastwards
across the barns uh here uh where there
is also a backdrop of further
residential buildings
um in the white immediate and wider
vicinity here
um finally here we are still at the
point of vehicle access
um looking along the b439 both away from
the village here on the left and towards
the Village Center here on the right
um having refused a scheme in this
location that was materially the same as
12 months ago it is officer's opinion
that previous concerns or massive
highways have since been addressed and
improved the proposal was seeking to
deliver three family homes a sustainable
location within the adopted Village
boundary of bidford and Haven I refer
you all to the update sheet for details
of the member's site visit that took
place this afternoon uh chairman the
recommendations to Grant this
application for a reason set out on
pages 15 and 16 of your agenda thank you
yeah thank you very much indeed let's
call our first Speaker of the evening
who is councilor uglus from bidford
Parish Council
not a counselor sorry I do apologize
Miss ugliest
I think you've been here plenty of times
you know the drill so you'll have three
minutes I'll give you 30 second warning
when you're ready the time is yours
good evening at the last meeting in
September when this planning committee
considered this application the parish
council raised objections due to the
dangerous access and loss of the best
and most versatile agricultural land
this committee has been able to see the
serious access problems at this site and
the parish council continues to
emphasize its real concerns about the
dangers of the Narrow Lane and its exit
from the site due to lack of visibility
which is the risk to Residents
themselves and to other traffic and
pedestrians on South abode and since you
have seen this at first hand I will now
focus on the other serious issue which
is the last the loss of agricultural
land at the September meeting I was
asked of this particular piece of land
was named in the NDP it is not however
the NDP was made in July 2017.
commitment by SDC to climate change
policies of which surely this must be
won
policy nv6 clearly states that the
development of the best and most
versatile agricultural land will not
normally be supported unless it can be
demonstrated that development is
necessary and no other land of a poorer
agricultural quality is available this
is clearly not the case in this instance
the policy further states that our best
agricultural land should be protected to
maintain the rural surroundings of our
Villages and to ensure it continues to
contribute to production of food whereas
it will be argued that the land is
currently not in cultivation it
nonetheless still is agricultural land
if you grant permission for this
development this land can be cultivated
can no longer be cultivated to produce
food and will be lost forever and not
replaced the parish council strongly
believes that the current Global
situation clearly shows the importance
of ensuring our green and pleasant land
remains that good agricultural land
should be protected and not built on
after all it's not as if bidford unaven
has not grown in the last five years
during which approximately 800 dwellings
have been built in view of this the
parish council would ask you to consider
very carefully the damage the loss of
prime agricultural land will have
compared to granting permission for
three more dwellings to be built in its
debt thank you
so close that's well within your time
thank you very much do we have any
questions members
councilor Cargill
thank you
um in your NDP you show the London
question within the uh the Via buab can
you clarify that please you mean it's
inside the built up area well yes it is
because you so many other buildings have
been already built on agricultural land
yeah the point I was getting at was that
is therefore in your NDP permission in
principle because it's within the
development in principle within the bill
to bury boundary shown in the NDP no
because in the NDP it says we will
protect the agricultural land even if it
is within the the built up area
any other questions members
no sadness thank you very much for your
time contribution this evening
okay our next speaker on this item is
cancer Fleming
I'm afraid not
Council Fleming why you're getting
yourself settled I'll just remind you
you'll have five minutes I'll give you
30 second warning but otherwise once
you're settled and ready to go your the
floor is yours
um I visited this site today
and I still object to this development
for summer all of the following reasons
the access width the minimum width
allowable showed on the drawings is 3.8
meters I physically checked it today
with a tape measure at the narrowest
point it's 3.44 meters
now bearing in mind that uh our um
works of fire and rescue service require
3.65 meters to service development this
is 250 mil shorter what it's supposed to
be
the developments against their NDP we've
just had a couple of questions about
that
um
and they don't they don't come anywhere
near our housing needs survey
the Ingress and egress is a contrived
solution the way it's shown on these
drawings there's a couple of things not
quite right about it as well
to the uh to on the Outward Bound side
of the village there's a bus shelter
in the mornings between 30 and 45 kids
right at that bus stop
so if you're trying to pull out of that
driveway
you can't see up the road
um
and they're there obviously in the
afternoon when they've been dropped off
that's that usually happens between 10
to 8 and 8 30 in the mornings and the
other thing as well is with 11 parking
spaces on this site
that's an estimated potential 30 vehicle
movements a day coming in and out of
that driveway
um
footpath is the chosen route for
crossing to the Avon estate you know 150
homes where mothers from dropping their
kids to primary school walk along the
front of that
we need some clarification on traffic
management because of the way this
driveway is going to be constructed
um you could have two way two vehicles
two ways at the entrance area
house number 24 which is next door
if they want to come out of their
driveway
it means they're going to be meeting an
oncoming car coming in the other way to
go into this development so now that
they've made it two ways that you can
have an outbound and an inbound the
castle number 24 are going to have to
Traverse the path to come down the right
hand side to ex dive downside sorry to
come out
so I think that that's a that's a bit of
a problem as well because it means that
Vehicles won't be just crossing the
footpath they'll be traversing the
footpath as well
so I think that that needs to be uh it
needs to be investigated uh and the
supplementary guide the manual for
streets
the extra display
the developer signed a b certification
that it doesn't own the land to widen
display so this is subject to a final
agreement with number one Harbor close
they don't own that piece of property
where they're going to extend that
driveway
the other thing as well with that is
where it shows the bin housing uh to to
hold bins on on bin day
they totally ignore the fact that
there's a telegraph poll in the middle
of that piece of that that width
um
the uh
the
telegraph poll is only 1.6 meters away
from the existing posts so even if they
spray it back behind the telegraph pole
you've then got to thread the thread the
bins through now with three houses every
fourth week There's four there's 12 bins
there usually nine you know nine every
two weeks so
for three hands that's a lot of bins to
be sitting there anyway and you've still
got to get cars past one another because
they'll be in part of that extra wide
part
um
now the other thing as well is I'd like
to bring up I brought it up last time
very briefly but I'll bring you up again
um in
uh let me quote the document because I
was asked to make sure I knew what I was
talking about
part pre part P of The Refuge and
recycling storage on the SPD
says residents should not have to take
their bin waste and recycling more than
30 meters to a bin storage area or take
their waste receptacles more than 25
meters to a collection point
that track is 70 meters long
so that's well in excess of what's
expected and the other thing as well
from what we understand ahead it's going
to be constructed the distance greater
than 30 meters shouldn't shouldn't be a
problem shouldn't be taken on especially
if the residents have to pull these bins
over rumble strips gravel paths or steps
that's going to be a gravel track it's
going to be a gravel track so let's say
I'll sum this up in in the nine points I
said last time a lot of the land
immunity
the egress visibility splay the bend in
the lane which doesn't show up on the
drawing the width is wrong it's not 3.8
meters it's 3.4
the bin stories problem and moving bins
down there every every time it's bin day
housing needs survey says no and our NDP
says no so that's about as much as I can
say
Council farming thank you very much
members do we have any questions for our
Ward member please
cancer Crump
s
very quickly um you mentioned as part of
your nine points in in the
representation loss of agricultural land
um when was it last year's is it still
in use and what was it used for please
um we didn't I don't think you might
actually clicked on there you've said
your piece I'm not going to ask you to
repeat it okay you've heard in the
public have heard it so can we just make
sure the mics do go red otherwise they
can't be picked up um cancer Cargill
next please
thank you um right just on the items and
you mentioned they're the nine items
could you just clarify him he says it's
not a requirement development in our
local Haze the needs housing survey when
was that last completed please
we
it was done in 2017 it's just due for
review now okay thank you
did I see a Handover on this site
Council Curtis
thank you
um
yes and you mentioned
um the width of the driveway being 3.4
meters you also mentioned the width
required by the emergency services for
Access I didn't quite manage to make
note of that could you just clone
yeah the minimum requirement for uh
we're actually fine rescue is 3.65
meters
so it's 200 millimeters short of that
thank you thank you
any other questions for our board member
no council Fleming thank you very much
your time contribution this evening
okay that's all our speakers done so
points of clarification to our officers
councilor Adam first please
um I believe part of the reason for uh
deferring it previously was to try and
get highways to come out to the site
visit
um I know I wasn't able to make it were
highways from the county able to make it
um we're going to be no there's no as
myself as planning officer was on the
site today uh as the point of contact
for clarifying questions on massive
highways and other matters but no there
was no County representative there this
afternoon
cancer candle thank you can we get a bit
more detail on the uh width of the of
the of the path
because obviously we've had we've got
two different versions of that certainly
thank you councilor uh for the for the
opportunity
um
we as officers can go by scale plans
that are submitted to us for assessment
um there is a plan on your screen now
which shows
um that the width of the proposed access
points were members wanted to prove that
would be 3.8 meters at the point here on
the blue line plan that extends to
um I've got the figures here actually in
case you can't see it it's four point
um 4.8 meters at the point of the gate
there
excuse me
um 10 meters there at the widest point
of the Bell mouth there that
incorporates the bin collection points
excuse me and
um the existing access which is supposed
to be widened
um so 3.8 meters it is what has been
proposed for the
counter Parry
thank you chair just for clarification
just for everyone here
um I'm right in assuming obviously that
you don't have to own the land to submit
a planning application and therefore
whilst the visibility splays cut across
um neighboring properties on either side
it's irrelevant that any permission has
been sought or negotiation at this
particular stage because when I visited
the site on Monday I noticed
particularly on the right hand side we
have a brick wall and then a boarded
fence on top so it would mean removal of
part of that brick wall of the
neighboring property could you just
confirm for the basis of this meeting
that that is my correct assumption thank
you councilor uh yes you're absolutely
right the applicant has been very
upfront with this they've signed
certificate being on the application
form to declare that they don't own all
of the application sites they have told
us in signing that certificate that they
have served notice on the occupiers of
number one
were members minded to approve a
planning application it is for the
applicant then to be able to
successfully Implement that planning
permission but members this evening
offices are satisfied side that all of
that has been done correctly
yes thank you Council Ralph please
thank you I'm following on from
councilor Paris question
um
if um
if the applicant wasn't to get that
piece of land then the egress and access
would be narrower and therefore is it
contravening what the highways have
asked for to make it a safe access and
egress
thank you councilor um were members
minded to Grant the applicant would be
compelled to implement this plant Vision
in full accordance with the plans of
which the one on your screen is there
um they would not be able to implement a
access that was narrower than the one
that's on your screen in front of you
um so if the hypothetical situation you
you laid up there if the applicant could
not for whatever reason secure that they
would be unable to implement this
planning permission lawfully
just to follow on from that if I may
um uh if committee reminded to Grant
would it be sensible or appropriate for
us to put a condition on that says that
that entry in egress would be completed
prior to developing the main part of the
land
um yes that is within your gift as
members this evening
um if you uh so wish
um I would say the office report has
considered clearly amongst other matters
as it's considered the highways access
Arrangements
um they officers incorporated three
suggested highways conditions that have
been put forward by the county
um again Worman was monitor approve this
scheme
I would I believe I've just realized and
forgive me because I missed this earlier
but condition eight says exactly what I
think I want it to say right so ignore
my last comment we'll move to councilor
Adam was next on my list
uh thank you um customer was quite right
there is a sort of telegraph poll right
where they are proposing to put the new
entrance
um at least based on you know the images
that I'm looking at
um are the presumably power company not
consultees and would they not have to be
able to what I'm not totally familiar
with the logistics of that and how that
may be an impediment to construction or
or whether it's relevant as planning
material planning grounds yes thank you
councilor the it is I've looked at the
submitted layout plans again looked at
the existing uh layout plan the
telegraph poll is shown to be outside of
the red line boundary
um however it is directly in front of
the red line boundary as you can see
here
um there is a telegraph poll that is
shown on the existing layout plan
um it is my understanding that would
presume would be in highways ownership I
believe I'm not 100 sure of that but
it's not within the red line boundary
um and in terms of have a has a power
company been consulted on this
application the answer is no
um if there are matters relating to
um development nearby a telegraph poll
that is potentially a civil matter that
could be looked at between the applicant
and the power distribution Network
um that would not prohibit members from
granting permission again if you were so
minded
okay next my list is Council Harvey
thank you Mr chairman
um I note uh the the question of the
um adequacy of the access the the
um the distance between one place
another is clearly contentious I'm I'm
concerned that there is no response from
The Works fire and rescue service do you
question one do you share that concern
um secondly could you confirm the purple
area on the diagram is sufficient space
for nine bins what are the number of
bins actually might be that adequate
space
um thank you councilor um first thing I
would offer from a sort of professional
view is that it's regrettable that
County Fire and Rescue have not replied
um officer did consult and invite them
to make a comment on this application
um it's not entirely uncommon that we we
don't receive a comment when when we
invite a consultant to offer one
um that would be a personal view given
matters of fire and rescue have been
quoted
um in in discussion of this application
and ask your second question
um offices are satisfied that as is
displayed on your screens here with my
cursor there offices are satisfied that
there would be provision suitably next
to this area of purple
um so this area where my cursor is here
to the right of the purple area would be
used for bin collection purposes
um I believe every three weeks for
collection
thank you presumably rather than every
three weeks it'll be on the usual rotor
through bifford yes that's my
understanding Council Curtis next please
thing and just a couple of points and
just to be absolutely clear there is no
separate footpath on this axis is there
uh no it's just a vehicle access points
um yes and but also I'm can you give
some clarification on on the difference
in width that we see on the plan which I
think you said is 3.8 meters and the
information
the the ward member has given us we're
at 3.4 meters can you explain the
discrepancy between those two
um I I can offer a view whether I can
fully give you a full explanation that
remains to be seen but I can only
express something I mentioned earlier we
have scale plans showing that the access
proposed access is 3.8 meters at its
narrowest Point
um I am aware
um councilor Fleming uh measured the
access this afternoon when I was present
at the member site visit
um I can't corroborate that figure that
that's been quoted and what I can
corroborate other figures that have
we've been
um informed and measured and offices
have measured the off the plans but yes
they've been measured off the plans
rather than actually on site correct yes
yeah
so just again to follow on from that
presumably in the same way as the uh
this little purple section if that 3.8
is not achievable
then the development can't go ahead
or there would need to be some sort of
agreement to make sure that it can be
achieved presumably the were members
minded to approve the applicant would be
compelled to implement this access in
full accordance with the plans that have
been put before us as officers and you
as members this evening that's probably
the most I can say on the hotel
councilor I okay fair enough sorry I'll
put you under pressure there uh cancer
Dixon please
thank you chairman if I hear cast my
mind back to 115 20 years ago there was
a time when if you could actually
develop three properties was absolute
maximum to come off a single axis things
might have changed a bit but I just
wondered whilst it would be
to be able to get to a property uh are
the fire service able to
do they insist on being able to get the
vehicle through there to the houses or
would they be able to operate from the
road
um there are instances where
I I'm not necessarily posting this for
this application there are instances
from a more General point of view where
there is a condition proposed where
there would be the installation of
things like fire hydrants and other
things of that nature if
if it were deemed to be that there was a
disaster objection whereby the fire and
rescue Authority replied and said there
is an objection that we cannot
um achieve uh Emergency Services access
that's not something that we have on
this application I hasten to add we
regrettably as I mentioned to councilor
earlier it's we haven't got a response
you're saying yay or no
um there is precedent whereby on other
applications they specify a minimum
width and I think canceller the
councilor Fleming mentioned it um 3.7
meters is what is quoted to us as
officers which I've had personally on
other applications as we've touched upon
the applicant has shown us scale plans
that this access is 3.8
um while we're on that I'll ask our
planning manager to come in and give
their view as well so Alice if you
wouldn't mind please thank you chairman
and yeah just to add to um something
Stuart just said I thought it would be
worth mentioning that um fire safety is
also considered by building regulations
so we obviously consult them as a bit of
a
um a double up really for it from a
safety point of view to make sure we
have covered all bases but obviously in
the absence of a consultation response
from them raising objection we have to
assume it it's it it's acceptable and at
building regulation stage they can
secure things such as sprinklers for
example if they don't think that the
access is wise enough for a tender to
get down there so that there is another
step with which this can be adequately
sorted at the building regulation stage
in the absence of a response from them
to the planning application
thank God it's very helpful
um next is Council Cargill please thank
you the
concern raised about the bus shelter and
the the queuing ETC and yes when I
visited site I do accept that there is a
visibility issue there is that um
something that you would consider to be
um sort of would be a problem to this
application going ahead from a safety
perspective and also the officer Mr
Fleming the Council of Heming sorry
mentioned about
um having to drive along the foot path I
can't quite visualize that but is that
an issue as well please thank you
councilor um I've got the uh visuals
that I showed a little earlier in the
presentation that's the bus stop on your
left in question
um officers in reaching their
recommendation of support this evening
have given full consideration to masses
of Highways access Ingress egress
matters of pedestrian safety vehicle
safety both for the occupiers and for
other Road users we have consulted with
County highways who have reviewed all
details and offered no objections
subject to some conditions positive
um
it would therefore be officers view in
my view this evening before you that the
highways Arrangement visibility displays
included is acceptable
um clearly that's for members to debate
and determine uh in your in shortly
um and
my apologies you asked me a second
question I believe like
thank you
I think you may have actually answered
that particular one because you've
addressed the invisibilities place I I I
I well thank you I believe I have but I
mean there's some other visuals in the
immediate vicinity whereby
um houses do cross immediately we've got
a view here not directly opposite the
application site there are existing
houses that also cross footpaths that
are currently in situ
um similarly on this visual slightly up
the road there are also instances where
a vehicle would have to cross the
footpath to get in and out of their
Drive
thank you Council Parry please
thank you
um I just wonder whether the officers
just could confirm the actual length of
the access
from the um
point of entry right up that is that
sort of 3.8 or whatever it is the length
of it and also to advise that if if
members were minded to Grant could we
stipulate a bound surface of that access
road because pulling bins down a
graveled drive that are heavy
um
could be really quite challenging
thank you councilor um yes I can give
you some figures the measurement from
the uh bottom of the site here on the
red line the point of the footpath up to
the gates here is 52 meters
um there is a further distance of
approximately 75 meters to the first
closest dwelling
um I haven't got an exact figure to go
right to the very top of the site from
the pavement but suffice it's a it's in
excess of that 75 figure
um but a minimum of 52 meters to get to
the point of the gates here
anyone else before I Chuck in a couple
myself no just while we're on that point
so um Council Fleming raised earlier
about the distances no more than 30
meters for I think Recycling and 25
meters for Waste when you're dragging
your bins you've just told us that is
just demonstrating more than that how
how have you considered that this
overcomes that requirement at an rspd
thank you councilor um officers report
on page 14 does cover uh matters of
waste and recycling
um it is agreed upon and accepted that
this Arrangement
um I may just quote the the report here
actually whilst the bin Kerry distance
residents would be longer than preferred
its most suitable arrangement for the
site and it's not considered to be a
barrier to approval this application
overall the waste management proposes
considered to be a suitable plan for bin
storage and collection you are correct
that the 30 meters quoted
um is in our supplementary guidance that
is a guidance document that offices uh
use in the in their determinations it's
not a hard and fast policy it's it's
supplementary guidance
um officers have considered massive bin
collection
um and have put the recommendation
before you this evening that it is
acceptable
so so ultimately that SPD is guidance
rather than policy correct and therefore
you have used your
uh understanding the site et cetera to
determine that actually for this site
it's okay yes that's correct okay if I'm
sorry cancer if I may I realize Council
Perry asked me a second question about
the condition for the surface my
apologies I actually miss it
um were members minded to Grants you can
install in uh can you can suggest a
notwithstanding addition to say that the
access Drive will be in a bound surface
or a hard standing surface
um were you minded to Grant
um we heard from Mr Lewis about the
agricultural lands now I when we went to
the site a lot of it at the site that
that I saw was overgrown brambles and
all sorts of stuff and then these
buildings are we actually losing is the
agricultural land around it or is that
the other side of the application fence
this application site and the
surrounding area is in agricultural use
um so the red line boundary before you
this evening is agricultural land there
are agricultural barns on site
um some of you have seen the condition
of the site you've just touched on it
yourself and there's some photos to show
you
um officer also considers this on page
12 of their of the agenda packs
um it is not considered it's been a
number of years since the slight was
last in agricultural use
um officer quotes that the land has not
been used for crop for many years and
it's unlikely to be suitable to return
to active agricultural use
um and it is also noted that the area is
very small by modern agricultural land
standards so offices are a view that
this would unlikely be able to be
brought back into agricultural use
understood thank you the driveway does
it have any lights on it
um I don't think it does it does not
it's not like I can see you know
okay that's my list anyone else before
we move into debate let's debate then
who would like to kick us off first
I'm going to start pointing fingers if
no one does council Rolf please
yes so did you you were on this site
visit today were you
so I I just wondered um
were you able to confirm or not confirm
the width of that access
or do you rely on your your the you know
the paperwork
uh are you happy for me to film yeah
yeah uh thank you Eric thank you
counselor um
I I was present on site
um I did not personally measure that
distance myself
um officers as I've touched upon can
only be guided by the scale plans that
we've got to assess
um we we have a distance of 3.8 meters
on the scale plans and that's what
officers have used for their assessment
if I may do a follow-up I mean because
you hadn't heard back from
um from highways from the um
the Emergency Services uh I I just
wondered whether you thought it might be
personal to actually double check
because you hadn't heard back from them
um officer has invited them for comments
that Unfortunately they did not reply
um I am hearing the guys this evening to
present this item on behalf of a
colleague officers
um have put their case forward in the
reports
um and so I say we don't have a county
response I'm afraid
um we we had moved to the debate but
we've gone backwards of touch for that
uh points of clarification
um let's move into debate now given
councilor Roth uh went backwards would
you like to kick us off in the debate
if I'm putting you under too much
pressure you can say no
I'd like you to start us off in the
debate
okay uh yes well why not because I've
been very new to this
um
uh I've got to admit I have concerns
about the um uh the emergency service
and the access and I have concern about
the access and egress and I have concern
also
um about uh ensuring that there is a
condition
on the surface of that access simply
because there is nothing worse than the
noise of dragging bends down the side of
that house of number 24.
so that's my start to the debate thank
you very much councilor Parry please
thank you chair
I think what we have in front of us is
really quite
um
it is
the reason it was deferred was obviously
that we wanted to go and have a look at
the access
um it is it has got
um a lot of challenges
um but on the face of it we have to look
in terms
of Grant or refusal for material
planning reasons and obviously the main
issue we have here is the access into
the site and we have a no objection from
highways Warwickshire County Council we
also have
um the positioning for proposed waste
and bins and whilst the applicant
doesn't own the necessary land to create
the visibility
display
that is that is not a material
consideration
but we also have guidelines in terms of
the recommended
distance
for bin collection
so on the surface of it I'm struggling
to find a solid material planning reason
to refuse on the basis this that this
would be very significantly conditioned
to
ensure that all the appropriate
um displays and visibility was overcome
so on that basis
um
whilst I don't like what I have in front
of me I have to go on material planning
reasons the site is within the
buab or that that has been recently
updated
the other consideration we have to think
about is the other neighboring
properties all access that main Salford
Road
um there is a very wide area in front of
the immediate narrowing Gateway at the
moment where cars can pull off and I
actually parked
right and my car was off the main
highway so there was certainly plenty of
room for a car to pause there and
actually another car pass so on that
basis I'm being forced to propose
recommendation of Grant with the
condition that we have a bound surface
up the track because I can't because
we've got no objection from Warwickshire
highways I don't have a material
planning reason to refuse chair thank
you very much Council Cargill please
thank you
that was very interesting we have a
10-year housing land Supply there's no
local need identified
so it's an open market development
the NDP shows that the site within the
buab but
it says that they should protect
um agricultural land and I fully agree
that we don't we're not growing land
anymore
there is damage to the wall but I think
in the grand scheme of things that's
relatively minor
and unfortunately let's go with cancer
parody I can't find any material
planning reasons to object to this
just to confirm are you second in cancer
Paris proposal yes thank you very much
cancer Curtis please
um sorry this is something perhaps I
should have asked for clarification on
I'm still concerned
about this discrepancy in the widths and
there have been other instances
um that have come before various
committees where there has been some
concern over the accuracy of
using scale plans and I just want to if
Emergency Services the Emergency
Services haven't responded but if the
Emergency Services were given the width
of 3.8 meters
then they would consider that there was
reasonable access if they were given a
width that was the 3.4 meters then they
may well come back and respond so I'm
just I I am concerned that there is this
apparent discrepancy if it is 3.8 then
then I would remove that that concern
but I do have a a bit of a an issue
about that
um and again if we were minded if the
committee were minded to Grant and agree
with comments made by Council Perry and
and well I think about having a bound
surface not only
um for
um in the Mover removal of bins sorry
movement of bins but also
um anybody using a wheelchair push
chairs which would be extremely
difficult over a non-bound surface
thank you thank you very much councilor
Kendall next please thank you chairman
um I think everything I wanted to say
has largely been said so I won't go over
all ground I in terms of the widths and
the access I think I'm right I'm saying
if something was wrong then the
application the application permission
would be withdrawn later on if something
was found to not be correct then that
that would fall at that stage I'm going
to go with the officer's judgment on
this one
um because I think that's good enough
and in terms of finding any other app
material planning grounds
as it's all been said I can't see any
strong playing ground so I would have
seconded if I had if I'd have the
opportunity
sorry about that uh councilor Adam next
please
thank you chairman um I I do agree that
I can't find any material grounds to
um
go against the officer's recommendation
as a proposal but I I won't be
supporting it because I think that from
my point of view it's almost been over
engineered to try and get a technicality
through our planning system and I think
the reality of that is we're being
forced to consider something which may
indeed be completely impractical to
build and that in reality that what will
be built won't be able to conform to
these plans and they'll probably try and
build it anyway that may be a cynical
View and that's my personal View and so
be it but that's I feel that as I'm
going to vote against it I have to
explain that reason but like I say um I
think the technicalities of it that our
officers have correctly assessed uh meet
our meet our guidance and so that that's
probably the reason why we can't find
any material grounds to go against them
so that's my view on it thank you thank
you councilor Ralph please
oh yes so how much um Credence can we
give to the neighborhood development
plan
um I.E is it a material planning reason
if it this piece of land is not
identified in their plan
um it is a made plan and therefore holds
material weight in the planning balance
it is a made plan and therefore holds
material weight in the planning balance
so if I may follow up so it can be a
planning reason to object that it is not
part of the plan
is am I is is that you can you can by
all means you can put that forward but I
don't think it's sufficient to overcome
um I will ask our officers to respond
directly but I don't think it's
appropriate to use that
thank you for the opportunity councilor
uh thank you Council as well the the the
bidford neighbor development plan has
full significant weight it is part of
the development plan that officers have
used to assess this application against
officers quoted NDP policies uh which
officers believe this pose was in
accordance of
um the development plan has been given
full assessment and its officer's
opinion that this development is in
accordance with that plan
um and that's where officers arrived at
Council cramp
yeah I just thought I'd come in um
to talk on this also um and explain that
I'm chair of um portfolio holder for
foreign rescue at the county
um
obviously there is the fire station just
up the road well relatively Road in
bidford so they will know the area well
and also fire and rescue do have
different size vehicles
um what they do is resource the risk
there's a community risk management plan
that's been out for consultation
recently and that's based on risk
um the the motto is prevention
protection response so there is all
about risk regarding that so I just
thought I'd make that clear
um so if that helps I know I don't know
why they haven't responded but I do know
that throughout this summer they had a
really particularly challenging time
amongst all that heat
and now since that Heat's gone they've
got loads of water everywhere so they
are under a lot of pressure at the
moment but I I don't know the reasons
why they haven't responded and I will
try and find out so just to make that
clear going back to the application I
hope that was helpful chairman
um I'll just then come in we do need I
think it's difficult to refuse this on
strong planning grants
and therefore I think we do need to have
strong and robust conditions
particularly around the heart standing
particularly around the bins
I do have some concerns about this in
our policies and guidance and whether we
do some equality
um e i I can't remember which stands for
now a quality impact assessment there
it's just good around these and and if
we do want people to live here but I
suppose if people are aware of the drive
before they buy it
um so they're not being forced but there
is that condition but I think we do need
um strong conditions around the hearts
London and going back to council Adams
uh point about a technicality and not
build it to like that I don't think that
it's strong enough as a planning reason
to refuse this application yeah I can
understand where it's come from and in
principle but again I I've you know and
if we if we refused it using that type
of words I think it would go to appeal
then we'd lose so that's just my temper
I hope it was helpful thank you
councilor Dixon please
I'll try and be brief
um listening to the parish council they
had two concerns I thought one was the
use of agricultural land I don't think
this has been agricultural land for a
while it may have old barns on it but
like the officers I do not anticipate
this coming back into food production of
any type uh in any uh decade shortly and
when it comes to the visibility space
yes there is a bus shelter but the
crowds there when the school children
the rest is momentary and therefore I
will be supporting the officer's
recommendation
thank you very much anyone else before I
just very briefly sum up
um uh so I think I agree with most of
what's been said both in terms of
um The Proposal but also some of the
concerns that have been raised
specifically the concerns that I think
are most prominent are the widths of the
access
um our officer has very kindly helped us
at least twice if not three times about
the the what we're looking at we did
measure on sites I was on the site visit
and we did measure on site the width
um not for one second suggesting that
Council Fleming's tape measure had been
adjusted anyway but of course it was
Council Fleming's tape measure
um so just to be mindful of that um the
reality is that the drawings do say 8.3
meters throughout that that width they
also say that they're going to widen the
front pun sorry three points
the people at one and two are suddenly
panicking thinking they're going to lose
some Garden there sorry about that 3.8
um that is what has been put in the
drawings that is what is clearly
indicated by the drawings and we have
conditions that say this must be built
out in accordance with those drawings so
they must meet that that 3.8 almost did
it again 3.8 now
um so I'm I will be going with those
recommendation and the pros that have
been put including that the bonded
surface what I would I wonder whether
it's worth uh expanding on um condition
eight which currently says access widen
as per plans prior to commencement of
the development to full length of access
widening so make sure that we do meet
and then that way we have our officers
and then able to say yes this has met
and we're going to assume you're
comfortable with that
yes is the answer I'm looking at
um the the access to be yes the access
to be warned as per the plans yes full
length so it's access widen and the full
length of the driveway I want because it
says say 8.3 oh 3.8
they'll say 3.8 on there we know it has
to be built out in accordance with the
plans I see no reason why we can't
include that because it's not onerous it
is what is in the plans and I just want
to be absolutely clear that that is done
before building work starts because what
I don't want to see is the building work
to be done and then find that the access
can't be uh sorry the access and the
length of the drive can't be put right
yes that can be accommodated okay so as
our proposal settings to cancer power
are you happy with that inclusion
Council cargo you happy with that lovely
that's two yeses so I'm happy with that
the proposal is to Grant with the
addition of the bonded surface condition
and the extension of the uh the driveway
width condition could I please have a
show of cancellation in favor of
granting
one two three four five six seven eight
nine nine and those against
two and one sorry and abstentions
one so committee therefore resolves do
you Grant application twenty two zero
one zero seven one ful in line with the
officer recommendation and with the
addition of those two uh conditions
okay
okay uh ladies and Gentlemen let's move
on to our next item of the evening
um
uh the application reference is twenty
two zero zero zero zero one ful that is
land near to Middle Road Farm in uh
harbory our presenting officer is Joe
Brook Joe whenever you're ready it's
over to you
thank you chair
the application site is located in the
open Countryside with within the Parish
of Harvey and often as indicated by the
indicative Plan before you
so as you can see this is often parish
and there's further plants clarifying
later
and this is Harvey just there
yep
the application is for the installation
of ground-mounted solar photo photo
panel
who's in the construction of the comms
Tower to enable a rated capacity of 4.99
megawatts
it must also be noted that the solar
farm if permitted is for temporary
permission of 40 40 years and six months
thereafter all equipment buildings
Associated infrastructure will be
removed in a
H College oh it's not me that
so this is the harbor e ffort is just
down there
the southern end of the application site
closest to every village in the Northern
and the application site Coast there you
can see Upton Parish I should also
highlight this is a grade two listed
building the Roman settlement is located
within this vicinity down here and this
area is also a soda farm called Radford
simile solar farm
so this is the southern end of the side
closest to harborry now as you can see
the substation site access Telecom
containers and all sort of main
buildings will be located in this area
this is the Foss leading up that area
and this is where it'll be located
within this section if permitted
this is a 15 meter tower that is
proposed for the development I'll
quickly go back to the other plan so you
can see it would be located within this
vicinity if permitted
and then this is the Northern end of
site closer too often
the panels which will obviously form the
majority of site will be arranged on
Metal Frames pushed into ground they are
to be finished in non-reflective dark
color to maximize absorption and with
extend to 3.1 at the highest point and
1.1 meters at their lowest the arrays
will be mounted on a single access
tracker mounting structure which will be
constructed from simple meta framework
mounted on piles that will be driven to
the ground that's avoiding any
substantive foundations the panels will
track the move and the sun throughout
the day they will be laid in North and
South rows with space in between each
row to allow maintenance as well as seat
grazing to avoid shading
so come to the site photographs this was
taken on this area here as you can
indicate this is where the solar panels
would be
um developed or installed if permitted
this is looking up so none this area
would actually be part of the so past
things but you can see it's relevant
because this is often and they would be
looking down so I'll flip pack that's
what they will be reviewing over that's
the edge of often and the driving is
coming down
this is taken from the lvia but I've
included it because it gives you a good
indication of the areas so this would be
the application site north of the field
as taken as you can see in the northern
corner there looking inwards
this is the Radford simile
um soda Farm in a minute and you see
that's how it's located and how it's
installed at this moment in time
this is one skin tank for the rvi for
obvious reasons it gives you the details
at the Middle Road
this is time from Google Earth because
once again it shows about our analysis
of sites to this is then taken looking
into the application like from this area
so this area would be
uh solar arrays
and this is then the other section taken
just off the fossil once again you can
see the distinguishing features within
the landscape
in conclusion in like the Casual climate
change emergency declaration the climate
change act can situate in the UK's
legally binding commitment to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions and the policy
stipulations of the mppf consideration
that this application will help reduce
CO2 emissions with an annual saving of
two twenty seven thousand one hundred
and eighty eight tons and is calculated
to provide electricity to around 14 500
homes the application is considered
Accord with the area's development plan
and as such officer recommendation is
for approval if I can draw your
attention to the update cheeks there is
a few
a member site visit was undertaken also
clarification when the officer reports
within the landscape section it is
stated 116 night says this is in
reference the agricultural land
classification the site is 89.3 as I've
already stated and also clarification on
the methodology electrical output as
well as clarifications on how it
counters CO2 emissions
thank you Joe thank you very much indeed
we will call our first speaker on the
seism whose counselor John Taylor
chairman of Upton Parish Council and I
believe we also have a Jackie Chapman
here to answer questions is that right
would uh would Miss Chapman like to come
forward just in case hello good evening
would you like to come and grab yourself
a seat at the front for me
you may not be called upon but it's
better to have you here in than not
so councilor Taylor you'll have three
minutes uh I'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up if you
want to stay seated afterwards with
questions otherwise whenever you're
ready the floor is yours
okay Council Taylor sorry can you just
double check your mics on I don't think
it's uh being picked up we do have some
glitches with our microphone so for
everyone I do apologize
if you wouldn't mind what I will do is I
will restart the clock and whenever
you're ready the microphone is now on so
you're good to go
uh yes I I represent the people often
um we are opposed to this uh this
development and I was about to say I I
thank Mr Brooks for actually mentioning
often
um when we first received the public
consultation about this
foreign
it's entitled
land at Middle Road Farm
often is mentioned once simply for
positioning it as on the north of the
site on the a425
later on
uh I received this one
planning site notice land near two
Middle Road Farm Middle Road harboring
when I received it somebody's written in
pencil here and often
and would you believe that before this
meeting started today
I've got another report
uh land near to Middle Road Farm Middle
Road harboring
um I would like to assure you reassure
you all often does actually exist
uh we're a tiny community of
approximately 200 people
uh
you have received uh I believe 27
objections from this small community to
this site
plus unanimity from the council to from
the Paris Council to support it
I know I'm being satirical but
one other person has said to me are they
trying to pull the wool over our hours
about over our eyes about this
okay
um I admit I've vented a bit of spleen
there
um but I do represent our Paris
let's stand back and have a look at what
this actually is
um from that two-dimensional plan
this is what it is
let's assume that you good people are
from harbury
you're very lucky by the way it's a nice
Village
and you unfortunate people live in often
in between the two Parcels of land which
this application really is
it's approximately two kilometers of
land as you can see on that diagram
there which isn't part of its
application 30 seconds
sorry 30 seconds
thank you
okay
Council Adam will speak next and focus
on the landscoping I would just like to
say that we are on board with with solar
if I lived in Harborough I would be very
happy with that proposal it's in the
right place
we know that Harbor supports the
application you are hearing that we
don't
I know Council Taylor I'm going to have
to ask you to wrap up you have exceeded
your three minutes now so you've got 10
seconds to wrap up I know you can't
approve half an application but Maya
respectfully asks that you consider
rejecting the application in its
totality and inviting the applicant to
come back to you with a proposal for the
harbury site
thank you for listening
thank you very much councilor I have
given you an extra 15 seconds I am now
required to provide that extra time to
both the applicant and to our Ward
member just so you you are aware I'm
sorry if I overstep that's quite all
right
um members do we have any questions
councilor Parry first
hello good evening councilor
um on the basis of your presentation
um
would I could you could you advise if
the applicant made any communication
with often Parish Council
um to explain
to consult with you about what they were
planning to do there has been no
consultation from the applicant apart
from this document of
nearly two years ago
am I right
oh they've made One telephone call to
the package clock
okay anyone else have a question for our
speakers
no in that case councilor Taylor Miss
Chapman thank you very much for your
time contribution this evening thank you
and we will call forward our next
speaker on the item who is Amos
Annabelle Roberts and I believe we have
a Mr Harry Wilder here to answer
questions as well so if I can invite you
both forward
hello and good evening I think you've
got a good idea of the drill now you're
going to have three minutes and 15
seconds I will give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up it looks
like your microphone is already on so
whenever you're ready feel free to start
good evening my name is Annabelle
Roberts and I'm here representing the
applicant for the proposed solar farm
and speaking support of the application
leicestershire solar one is a subsidiary
of Canadian Solar an international
leader in renewable energy generation
who together with novaji are the
Developers
in 2019 Stratford District Council
declared a climate emergency such action
highlights the necessary changes to
adapt to the effects of climate change
which can no longer be ignored noting
this summer was England's joint warmest
on record since 1884. this application
will help to significantly tackle these
issues through increasing renewable
energy generation and reducing carbon
emissions where over 27 000 tons of
carbon will be saved annually
The Proposal will produce enough clean
renewable electricity to power 14 500
homes cutting harmful greenhouse gas
emissions the application will help to
meet National commitments and
obligations set out by the government
and its Net Zero strategy it will also
make a valuable contribution towards
addressing the current energy crisis
we're in while providing energy Security
in the long term
the site has been carefully selected and
lies outside of any statutory
environmental planning and Landscape
designations and allows for a viable
in-field connection to the electricity
Network the vast majority of the land is
subgrade 3B and is therefore not best of
the most versatile land in addition to
the generation of renewable energy
ecological benefits which are called
with core strategy policy CS6 include a
biodiversity net gain of over 30 percent
a dedicated ecological enhancement area
with Wildflower Meadows and Boundary
Wildflower seeding as well as tree and
Woodland understory planting to improve
visual screening of the site
since submission we have engaged with
officers and provided further details to
address queries raised by Warwickshire
County Council highways Network Rail and
be landscaping design on behalf of the
council and none of these consultees
raise an objection the applicant also
decided to remove panels from the field
closest to Westfield cottages and an
updated site layout and Landscape
mitigation plan was provided the
landscape effects of the scheme have
been independently reviewed by Bea who
raised no objection to the assessment or
the cumulative impact of the development
the proposed landscape planting across
the site will reinforce a green
infrastructure Network in line with
policy cs7 the application will ensure
the viability of the farm and its
continued agricultural operations for
food production alongside the production
of green energy existing grazing land
which makes up a large proportion of the
site will remain as sheep farming the
arable land will be converted for
grazing reducing the need for
fertilizers and chemical sprays while
allowing biodiversity to thrive
developing this site for renewable
energy has been demonstrated to be
acceptable and in accordance with
policies of the core strategy in
particular policy CS3 sustainable energy
as well as the national planning policy
framework 30 seconds as you're aware
officers have recommended approval after
carefully weighing up the balance of
planning considerations I therefore
respectfully request members to Grant
planning permission in accordance with
your officer's recommendation thank you
Mr Roberts thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions
councilor Cargill first please
okay Council off thank you very gracious
of you
um uh thank you
um the previous speaker mentioned that
the applicant hadn't uh been in any
discussions with often parish council
could you tell me why that why you
didn't yeah I believe that to be um
incorrect I know that there were
conversation there was a phone call that
um and a couple of phone calls I think
contact was made
um I actually have um our applicant here
with a sort of developer so Harry might
be able to say a little bit more about
that would you like me to if you turn
your microphone on you certainly can
thank you very much
um yes so I have personally reached out
to both harbury and often's Parish
Clarks and I've spoken I had one very
long conversation with Austin's Parish
Clark who's here this evening I have
called on several other occasions but
been reached by the voicemail I have
left voicemail and was instructed that
they needed to speak to each other about
exactly what they wanted in terms of the
community benefit that we're proposing
any criticism or comment that they would
have had would have been taken into
consideration unfortunately we can only
engage with people who want to engage
with us
thank you very much councilor Cargill
please
thank you you mentioned Community
engagement
um you're offering I believe correctly
saying a certain sum of money for this
whereas other suppliers of solar Farms
have offered a more generous I.E 10 of
the energy after a period of time that
goes back into the local community is
that not something you would care to
offer
so Community benefits and the
contributions that different projects
make are a difficult thing to view in a
like by like basis in our industry a lot
of the larger more generous
contributions that were made were made
in the days of subsidy as we all know
here today that solar doesn't get a
subsidy anymore and that means we can
only afford to offer what we what we're
giving Which is 50 000 pounds and that
will be divided amongst several
organizations some of whom we've
identified during the consultation but
we're also happy to leave that open
until energization when the payment will
be made if you have any examples of
these sites that are being that generous
I would be interested to see them
because I don't think that would
certainly wouldn't stack up for us
unfortunately
may I chairman
um but Drayton just up the road from us
I did that the first time
um that was a 50-day quarter as well
49.9 because I know it comes under the
boundary
um right the second item um you
mentioned about biodiversity and all
this good things
um and also the fact that it is possible
there's lots of cans and ifs and buts
but possible for animals to roam under
the panels for uh but I
also heard from other developers that
they don't allow animals in because of
potential damage to the actual
um solar panels so in this case will
animals be allowed to roam and graze
underneath the panels
when you say animals are you meaning
sheep grazing the site or that mammals
can come
through free
not rabbits sheep
absolutely the land holding at the
moment is a large majority of it is for
sheep grazing and that activity is going
to continue and some people can be
cynical about that so show me a solar
farm whether sheep grazing and I can
name a few in in gloucestershire you
know where we're from but actually it's
a benefit it's it saves the developer um
you know having to mow and pay for
maintenance that the Sheep do it for
free so it's actually no it does serve
them well rather than just you know
saying something for PR but it will be
you know it will have that dual function
for energy use and and for sheep grazing
for sheep rearing which will continue
the food production of the site
thank you very much I'm just going to
remind members and everyone else that we
we are tight for time we've got a lot to
get through tonight so if we could
please keep our questions concise and
pointed and any points we want to make
concise as well that'd be helpful
Council Crump please
the good news is Mr chairman uh Council
can't ask my question
that's good that is concise I'm happy
with that cancer Dick's the next place
thank you chairman uh two questions if I
may um the Parry often Parish Council
stopped itself that uh one site was
acceptable to them one site was not
acceptable to them is it a situation
whereby it only becomes viable if you do
both
um
yes it is I mentioned earlier today that
um we don't receive a subsidy and the
reason why the project is decided is is
because of the available capacity and
the need to build a particular type of
substation in order to um to connect
obviously you take that connection cost
and you apportion it against the amount
of megawatts you're able to install
reducing down to half simply wouldn't be
viable
thank you and uh I understand that the
panels themselves were as it were
followed the sun does that mean that
they start Facing East and end facing
west or north east to Northwest through
South
so Canadian settlers are committed to
developing the best the most
technologically advanced sites we can in
the UK single access trackers are
relatively new technology with only a
few sites built so far in the UK but
they've been successfully deployed
abroad the principle is that instead of
a fixed traditional array which runs
from east to west and faces South the
roads run from north to south and they
will start the day facing to the to the
east rotating across a single axis
across the day to face West that means
that you utilize the panels to a much
higher extent throughout the day and
what that does is not only does it
produce more power but it also produces
more power at the start and at the end
of the day making solar a more reliable
contributor to our national network
thank you very much uh councilor Parry
next please
thank you chair
um it is normal for developers of large
schemes to go and present their plans at
the respective Parish councils can you
just briefly explain appreciate you've
made some phone calls could you just
explain why you felt it wasn't necessary
to go and present your plans at a parish
council meeting
so Canadian server with our development
partner novelty has a number of
strategies that we employ throughout the
UK obviously during covert we stopped
doing these the physical consultation
events entirely and for some projects we
have brought them back in this instance
the planning and development team
decided that a community consultation
event wasn't the way to go for this
project and instead engaged with a
website with the paper leaflets that
have been received to people's homes and
also directly if they were contacted by
concerned constituents I have personally
engaged with several members of the
community to amend our plans as already
stated
cancer Harvey please
thank you Mr chairman
um in order to Advocate your case you do
make a calculation on the number of
houses that could be powered as an
equivalent an argument against is food
security
um
can you tell me if there is any impact
on food security by the installation of
this proposal and if so what sort of
scale of magnitude would that decrease
in food security be
um well we said that the renewable
electricity provided will provide
provide enough electricity to power 14
500 homes the use of the site will
continue as agriculture it's already
over half of the site um well over half
is already grazing for sheep production
the rest is arable and that will be
converted into grazing which could be
used to increase stocking densities for
more food more you know more sheep
reading more lamb or it could be left um
you know as grazing so it's it's
actually in some ways beneficial to the
farmer for viability because they don't
have to pay for food to come in you know
they can have more grazing rather than
kind of paying
um for um additional food over the
winter and hay Etc
um so I don't think it's going to make
much difference it will carry on you
know what they're doing now it's not
going to change they're going to carry
on farming as sheep farmers
Council Curtis please
thank you a couple of questions can I
just first one very quickly
um we've got two separate sites here how
will they be connected will there be
overground cables underground cables
um along the um the first way or the
verges of that and then connect back in
into the northern part of the site and
it will all be an underground
connections okay thank you and my other
query is on the 14 500 homes
my I'm not a mathematician but
the average annual consumption per meter
domestic consumption per meter in
Stratford District
is 4 800 kilowatts
that times Fourteen and a half thousand
gives 69 megawatts
um
the figures you have here of nearly 50
megawatts by that calculation
um would be enough energy for 10 200
homes so just wonder
how given that the average consumption
say per meter in domestic is four
thousand eight hundred and how we arrive
at the figure of 14 500.
I think there are different ways of
coming to that number
um Harry could you advise any more how
we got to that
I appreciate what you're saying it's an
incredibly difficult thing to um to try
and look at the numbers and work out
exactly what it's going to exactly what
it's going to be obviously the scheme
itself is a 49.9 megawatt solar farm but
that doesn't mean that that is the
annual production of the site now the
site's production figure I don't have
with me but it is a figure that we model
when we do the financial modelings for
the site and we then take that annual
figure and then we take the the
government National figure for the UK
and divide that figure
by that obviously Stratford's figure May
well be much higher than the national
figure I believe the national figure is
nearer to 3800 which of course we can
only and we probably as developers
should try and use National figures not
those cool so that we are otherwise we
could use different figures whereas the
country that were vastly different we
need to get some continuity in the
industry for how we describe our schemes
because we appreciate they are very
technically
complex in some ways and it is difficult
to make sure that is there's a clear
message for how much energy is provided
thank you I just
I don't quite agree
um with your assertion that
we should we should be looking at
National figures because we are looking
at this I'm going to ask you to ask a
question rather than debate the pros and
cons of capital I will leave that for
debate good man thank you I would also
Drive one's attention to the update
sheet which does give a calculation of
uh the megawatt hours and the number of
houses as well
uh did anyone else have any questions
for our speakers
um I just want to clarify you with the
connection between the North side and
the South Side you said it's going to be
an underground wide connection along the
Foss way is that correct
or is it going to be over the fields
it will be an underground connection
from if you just have a look at that
drawing there the South Western corner
of the north and northern part so you'll
see the red line extends to the Foss way
the cave will then run either in the
Verge or in the highway under Section 50
down to the southern site where the
primary substation and point of
connection onto the local distribution
network is located
lovely thank you very much if there's no
other questions which I don't believe
there are thank you both very much for
your time contribution this evening
okay we'll call our last speaker on this
item who is counselor Adam
councilor Adam come on down
now you of course normally have five
minutes we do give you an extra 15
seconds so you've got five minutes and
15 seconds feel free to use as much or
as little as you wish whenever you're
comfortable and ready the time is yours
thank you very much uh thank you
committee um I say this is a very
difficult application for me
um I do I'm actually a massive supporter
of uh solar in our district and even in
my ward um I voted for declaring a
climate emergency and I accept that this
means compromises have to be made
um we have to scrutinize the
applications we see from a larger
picture
um but also from the point of view of
our residents to ensure that the impact
that these developments have are
sensitive to and inclusive of
um the communities that we represent who
ultimately have to live with them
um
in with that in mind uh we should not uh
not let the solution to our climate uh
problems also take away what we're
trying to save that's why I'm here
tonight uh to represent my residence uh
and I also say that I think that I don't
bring this to a committee lightly I
think it's just important that we are
able to scrutinize these types of very
large applications in the proper way to
make sure they're done properly
um I'll start by saying that there's a
there is actually much about this
application I do support uh the carbon
offset
um increase in uh net biodiversity
economic benefits are welcome positives
and the the community benefit fund
contribution is is appreciated
um
I noticed that there there is positive
sport as well from residents
um albeit there they'll be elsewhere in
um in in the district from from my patch
um as well as the objections and the
harbury parish council have no
objections at least to the parcel in
their Parish uh I have no views to the
country uh for the southern part of land
however uh the reservations that I uh do
have can't be overlooked regarding uh
the adjacent of the area adjacent too
often uh being the northern part of the
site
the impact on land State landscape
stands to directly negatively affect the
wide open landscape and often residents
Topography is extremely important in
this case
um the parcel uh the northern parcel is
directly below the village of Upton
um every property on the west of the
village including the pub Garden the
white heart will directly Overlook the
northern parcel of the site
um I appreciate the proposed conditions
for hard and soft Landscaping however
the elevation difference between the
center of the village and the nearest
field being developed is about 40 meters
or 131 feet
um no amount of soft Landscaping can
overcome this I think that was mentioned
earlier by the officer
um
you will also recognize that the
existing solar array adjacent to the
Foss way which is um sort of observable
on the plan
um is between the parcels this is uh
positioned as another one uh in in such
a way
that is more secluded
um being still visible but a much more
significant distance from often and is
less visible from the road and so has a
relatively small impact on the landscape
which is the type of arrangement that I
can quite happily support uh for
reference though this existing array is
approximately a fifth of uh the proposed
Northern parcel alone or thereabouts
um the officer states that they
acknowledged that the application will
cause a level of harm by urbanizing the
currently undeveloped agricultural
fields and CS5 A2 States proposals
should protect landscape character and
avoid detrimental effects on features uh
which make significant contributions of
character history and setting of The the
settlement area
it's clear from seeing it that the
Overlook one house from often makes this
land part of a valued landscape and
therefore given the scale of development
the harm cannot reasonably be mitigated
in this location
um as has been mentioned before in this
committee if it's not right it's wrong I
feel despite all the benefits that
applies here and that more Works needed
to make it right which I would welcome
I'd urge that this application is
refused now so that it can be amended to
it exclude the more damaging parts of
the application in which I see is the
northern parcel and possibly have other
nearby areas considered for solar but
will not have such a severe impact on
the landscape and residents allowing us
to address the climate emergency in the
district whilst taking our residents
with us
cancer Adam thank you very much well
within your time members do we have any
questions for our award member please
Council Dixon please
thank you chairman
I asked the uh the developer as to the
orientation of the uh of the solar panel
as such now looking at my map I think
the development if it proceeds uh the
northern part at least will be more or
less to the almost Due West of Austin
and therefore in the early morning those
panels will be facing often in the first
morning of light uh by lunchtime perhaps
facing away come evening
um facing opposite direction do you
think that that's changed throughout the
day
we'll have a
I have no improvement on the landscape
impact certainly often it is above
you're looking down on it certainly
facing when it's in the morning it's
been seeing the panels in the evenings
perhaps not
yeah I mean my view on sort of the
visibility of it is it's development on
the whole and as I say the sort of the
um the urbanization of the landscape is
the thing that I'm more concerned about
I think there are technical aspects that
which probably make it less egregious in
some ways uh and I know that some of
those are related to in the the glint
and glare assessments that have been
carried out but I think it's more the
development of whole fields on on the
whole being such so close to the Village
that's the that's the area of landscape
detriment that I'm coming from more than
the technicalities of of how they affect
them over the day
that's a cargo please
I think I think it's being answered um I
I'm happy with the answer that counts
very good
anyone else have a question for our war
member no in that case councilman thank
you very much indeed right let's move
towards gratification anyone have any
clarification for officer councilor Rolf
please
uh yeah I wonder if you can help me so
on page 35
um the paragraph about moderate impact
uh where Reflections are predicted to be
experienced for more than three months
per year or for more than 60 minutes per
day the impact significance is moderate
um can you just elaborate on that is it
are you talking about is this seasonal
uh yeah it's seasonal so basically it's
set on the Clinton glare assessment
um
it might be worth showing the garage
session quickly because I have got it up
two seconds
so as you can see it under Section 1.33
it shows the glint and glare assessment
of it and hold the 22 Main dwellings
they've done receptors throughout the
day of all areas of the dwellings that
have been located and the impact on them
um is highlighted that there will be 30
years some impact but overall that
Embark isn't considered to be relatively
measurable
um so if I may I mean we're if we're
talking seasonal I mean we've had an
unseasonable season recently in the
Summer where it's been incredibly hot
for a lot longer than three months and
in fact I'd argue tomorrow is going to
be 20 degrees which is summer weather
so so I I I'm still confused as you you
pinpoint it to three months well you've
also got the tilt on access and all that
I mean the problem being with that
assessment is yes it's been a very hot
year but the glint and Gary assessment
has been undertaken by professional
experts so that during their assessment
is undertaken include in the whole
seasonals and average every year I can't
it's been done by professional experts
at the work and also it states within
the assessment worst case scenario
thinking answer to your question Council
roll it doesn't matter how warm the day
is the earth still tilts on its axis and
autumn and winter and summer and spring
still progress throughout the year and
that's the basis of the calculations
that when the sun is at a certain angle
to the Earth this is what will happen
that's what that point is making in the
airport and like I said it is worst case
scenario it's not just on the best
Solutions it's worst case scenario I set
up and Report
Council Cargill please
a couple of our nature
um first it says a 40-year
temporary period which is a generation
actually quite interesting as a as a
temporary period so not really that
temporary um the other solar Farms have
had a 25-year period why not why not
this particular one
because that's what they're proposing
it's the application for us first thing
and it's what it's not just that you've
also got to consider the benefits over
40x Market years in an Ideal World
hopefully in 25 years renewable energy
is such a place these aren't required
and it could be removed but at the
minute that is 40 years we'll supply 14
000 and 500 ohms of electricity that's
pretty yeah okay thank you the um
the other one was Landscaping now and
the Drayton Farm which if I catch in
mind black eye was actually chairing
that particular meeting we are we have
spent a lot of time discussing
Landscaping uh to mitigate the impact of
the farm and I don't believe any of
that's actually been implemented on that
farm because certainly not alongside the
the a46
I'm going to ask the question if if the
committee is minded to ground plane
permission how can we robustly enforce
the planning of the Landscaping on that
site please because obviously it's um
important and finally by major in the
conclusion page 33 it states the land
shall be adequately restored at the end
of temporary permission uh is this
actually enforceable or a reasonable
condition
so the first one is obviously conditions
of being proposed for it for the
landscape and harm not a lot to be
submitted
you have your writers the Committees
decide actually if you want to impose
certain uh time scales to that so let's
say six months when it being turned on
so if it's not imposed within them six
months they're in Bridge
I will always be honest that will then
be an enforcement investigation on it
but it will be imposed in them sort of
areas so if you want to put them tiles
guys on I don't know on the Dragon one
if those time scales were imposed
in the assets second question the reason
that shelves in is because the
decommissioning statement will be
condition and unpreferably I would like
to get the use of the land better than
what is right at this moment in time so
it's basically what the decommissioning
statement will say and if we agree it
will be suitable for the area at the
minimum it should be returned to what it
is
okay
anyone else with any points to clarify
no let's open up debate who would like
to kick us off
if I don't see a hand I'll Point Castle
Ralph please
no thank you chair
I find it
find it magnitude
the company didn't fill it necessary to
kind of do a face-to-face consultation
and felt that a phone call was was
adequate I find that a little bit
insulting really to those that live so
close by
councilor Perry please
always me isn't it
um
I'm I'm a great advocate of
solar energy
but when it's in the right place
and it reflects
the right
um
minimal harm to the landscape I mean we
currently have a number of neighboring
solar Farms
I think my biggest issue with this
particular application is the split site
because actually in my view then the
harm is more enhanced
because the solar farm isn't condensed
to
one particular area
um I don't have a problem with the
um
the area the site apportioned in harbury
I think that makes a good fit and in
fact if
the adjacent field if it extended in a
continuous way there would be less harm
but I do have
um concern that it gives a sort of
cumulative impact as well with the
Radford simile site
um I feel there is therefore significant
harm on the landscape but
attended the site visit this afternoon
and no amount of landscaping will
overcome the issues that we have here
um I therefore it's a very large area so
for me it also fails on design scale and
layout because we've got two disparate
sites
um if one takes our policy CS5 on
landscape
that any development any proposals
must have regard to the local
distinctiveness and historic character
of The District's diverse landscape
um the issue I also have
it it causes because you've also got
um solar panels that track and turn I
feel that has an urbanization impact on
the village of often
um and I'm there for for those
plant material planning reasons
I propose to refuse
thank you very much Council Cargill
please
thank you Chad well the struggle does
appear to be covered in solar Farms
these days isn't it I'm a supporter so
that but it does take up significant
amounts of valuable uh land but In
fairness the main concern I had was loss
of productivity of that land and I have
been assured by the applicants that the
Sheep grazing under it will be retained
and therefore we haven't lost the
productivity of that land
I hope that's the case
um if I may I was a bit I'm happy with
some of the ifs and books and candies
and anticipates on page 29 which made or
making my decision harder
we have a Target becoming carbon neutral
both this Authority and the country and
this will inevitably contribute to that
goal
um previous schemes that I've seen
have the same objections
In fairness
that was not the case it didn't impact
as badly
as perhaps first thought and they do
fall into the background eventually it's
a bit like large-scale glass houses
and those were that were impact as well
on that
this is a planning balance
and on the one hand we've got harm
perhaps to the land and the visibility
Etc on the other we are producing more
solar energy
therefore I'm willing to support the
officer in this particular case thank
you Mr Sun clear councilor cargo are you
proposing Grant
yes I am thank you
Council Curtis please okay
um
I mentioned this
disparity between the
um the number of homes and I just think
I just find the found the reply that the
applicant needs to use National Data
or national measurements
when making this presentation
um you know we're here to look at the
impact and benefits to Stratford
District I mean that's that's why we've
been elected so I it's a it's a small
small point but I think we need to
question and say the the national
average is 3 800 kilowatts per household
in Stratford it is 4 800. it may not be
a material planning consideration but I
think it is information that is relevant
and that we need to challenge these
figures when they are presented to us to
ensure they are representative of what
our requirements
okay thank you very much Council Harvey
please thank you Mr chairman um
I've got a
solar panel Farm in my ward and it is
separated from the Minor Road that it
but by field and I notice
um there's something in Congress about
the residents or the parish council from
often
um being objecting to the northern
portion whereas the parish council from
harbury in relation to the southern
portion I presume doesn't raise an
objection
um
I've driven down the road from often
down to the force along the force and
back into harbury and my impression is
that
the impact from bio by a road user would
be relatively small I drove particularly
past the existing site on the Foss
and if you drive one way you hardly
notice it at all you drive the other way
you do notice it somewhat
but
um my my view I think is on on balance
and it is on balance I accept there is
some visual harm is that uh I would
support councilor Cargill I I do think
the answer we were given into the in
relation to the question about
um food loss food security was difficult
to accept because if I heard it
correctly
the logic of it would mean that if there
were more solar Farms on more
agricultural land we'd have both solar
solar output and increased agricultural
output that is intuitively difficult for
me to accept but on balance I'm prepared
to go with Grant
uh just so I'm clear is that a seconding
of cancer cargo's proposal second thank
you very much
um councilor Eden next please
thank you chair
um I'll be honest I was very much on the
side of going with Grant on this until
councilor Perry changed my mind
um
I think she makes a very good point
about that cumulative effect and the
almost pincer-like movement of what's
going to go on with the tilting and
turning um so I will gladly second uh
cancel the Paris proposal
thank you very much you haven't heard me
speak yeah so I might change your mind
back
um councilor Crump next please
thank you Mr chairman I'll see you on
the earlier a while
um and I know that um buffton has been
particularly affected by our friends hs2
um which is let's cut them off
um and done significant damage to to the
landscape
um so yeah it's it's certainly not
certainly not fair
um obviously we're being told that hs2
is the major national infrastructure and
Stratford District Council should bear
its uh brunt of that and in the same way
I think the energy climate emergency
we do have to provide a contribution to
National infrastructure
we need to become more less reliant on
fossil fuel fuels and we need to be
really less reliant on
supplies from from abroad because they
can we know recently
they can be difficult to get at times
especially when there's competition as
well and I'll just leave it as that
um
we've uh somebody mentioned the glass
houses in the same effect and it's quite
noticeable there are significant glass
houses both north and south of the first
roundabout
um and some are quite close to the
existing solar panels that I'd along on
the safe side of the a425 at the fast
way
um so I'm on the climate Community
climate change panel
um and I do support this application uh
reluctantly
um but I think we do need to consider
the national good the greater good and
also the fact that
when we've got a lack of supply
of electricity for our residents that
we've been told that potentially
in January February some of our
residents could be losing the power for
three hours at a time I think we do need
to take steps that we are more secure in
our supply of electricity to our
residents
thank you very much councilor Kendall
please I think chairman everything has
been said basically that I was going to
say I'm just going to finally say if
we're going to get serious about
um about climate change and providing
renewable sources of energy we're going
to have to make some very difficult
decisions I will be supporting the
recommendation to Grant
thank you very much Council roll please
I'm a counselor haven't gotten before me
because uh councilor Parry has changed
my mind also and I think it will have a
much bigger impact on Afton
than it will on Harbor and I uh there
will be that kind of element of
urbanization and I think that is a a
planning reason actually to refuse it so
I would support the no campaign if you
like
thank you very much Council Dixon please
thank you chairman
I've supported each solar planning
application that's come before this
committee over the last few years but on
this one I can't
having attended that site visit this
afternoon and viewed the northern site
as it were from the confines of often
essentially I find it an impact on the
landscape and I'm on councilor Perry's
side on this particular one so it'll be
an interesting vote Jim
I was just thinking the same thing
Council for me
thank you jet excuse me
um yeah I've struggled with this one I
must admit but listening to all the
arguments and the what the thoughts that
have gone on today I think I'm going to
have to go with counselor Perry and go
in the no camp
okay anyone else before I Chuck in my
thoughts see if I can convince some
people
um I don't necessarily disagree with
what everyone has said both on the pros
and the cons
um
clearly often sits on top of a hill it's
certainly higher than the application
site so inevitably their views are going
to be damaged it doesn't matter whether
it's solar panels or a farm or buildings
houses whatever it might be anything is
going to change that landscape and it
will have harm as a result of that
um what I'm trying to do is balance that
harm and how much harm that that is in
my view relatively limited certainly
from the um the consulties even our own
conservation officer has said limited uh
weight sorry limited harm
um Natural England I noted haven't got a
comment uh normally on something like
this Natural England would be sending us
a lot of information about whether they
are for or against so we've had nothing
from them I I give weight to that
um I also balance that with the weight
uh um that Council Crump spoke about the
desperate need that we have to be
self-reliant on our own sources of
I'm so sorry my microphone turned itself
off I hope you got all that
um so I'm weighing both in the balance
um
I think this is a case in point of
electricity problems
thank you
we'll get there we will get there it
doesn't want this thing obviously
doesn't want me to say what I've got to
say I think you've got the general gist
of it I'm giving much more weight to the
need for us to to produce that energy
um and the need for us to provide that
so I will be going with Grant we have
had two proposals both of which have
been second
right everyone give me their microphones
um
right let me try that again we've had
two proposals once Grant one to refuse
the one that was seconded first was the
grant so we must listen to that first if
that fails we will then take the second
proposal which is to refuse and has been
seconded what I will want to do if we
get to that stage is I want to really
draw out more around the reasons for
refusal so while we're going through
this process if you could please put
your minds to that that would be very
helpful
um so could we please ah now before we
go to the vote what I would also add in
so I think councilor cargo you propose
the grant
um I have concerns about the connection
between the two sites
um I'm not clear exactly where it's
going to go and I don't understand I
don't believe that the uh alignment and
the and the delivery of the connection
is part of this application certainly it
sounded like an s51 I think was going to
be required so I think we need to add in
a condition for engineering connection
operations are you happy for that to be
added yeah I did think it was part of
the section 150 it was one five one is
it oh one five one I thought it was but
anyway I'm happy to go I think to be
belts and braces I think I'd be more
comfortable to include that so if you're
happy that's great that was seconded uh
by Council Harvey you're happy with that
Edition marvelous so with that addition
let's have a vote on that so the
proposes to Grant within the edition of
the engineering operations condition
favor please
three four five and those against
one two three four five six so that
therefore fails so uh we will move then
to the proposal to refuse now I will
need to draw out more detail on your
reasons for refusal please
thank you chair my reasons for proposing
refusal is on
impact to the character of the landscape
CS policy CS5 and also policy cs9 which
is design and distinctiveness which also
highlights the topography and scale and
size of the proposed application
are you happy provided this obviously
does get supported by the members of the
committee are you happy to leave the
wording of all that to officers I am but
also I was on impact to cs9 it creates
an urbanization to the Village of
um often
and there is also
um whether it can also be included is
the cumulative impact because of another
neighboring solar farm and I think if I
just want to stress it is the northern
aspect of this application
that is the issue not the harbury end
because the it's the impact is on often
with the character the landscape
particularly when we were standing today
from the um Gardens of the white heart
which is a public
that it is a public realm The View onto
that landscape but I'm happy to leave
the officers
I okay that perfect I think that's
sufficient
um uh I don't think we would be within
the condition we'd be able to say this
is because of that part not this part so
it will be an all-encompassing rather
than singling out one quarter or another
but I think I've got I've written down
three possibly four things here and I
can see Joe's written the same thing are
you guys happy that we've got sufficient
there to be able to proceed to a vote
Yes okay let's go for a vote so for
those nearly is there anything you want
to add to it are you happy I think
that's wonderful forgive me I should
have called you counselor and I
apologize
um
just check with the manager
I certainly can Alice have you got
anything you want to add at this point
no I don't thank you I think that that
summarized everything really well I've
taken notes of uh councilor parry's
initial kind of comments when she
proposed to refuse and which is
reiterated so I think we've got enough
detail there to be able to formulate a
reason for refusal lovely thank you very
much okay let's move to a vote then so
the proposal is to refuse planning
application 22001 ful could have a show
of hands please in favor of refusal
one two three four five six and those
against refusal one two three five four
five so committee therefore resolves to
refuse application twenty two zero zero
zero zero one ful that is land near
Middle Road in harbury for the reasons
given now members I did say earlier on
uh I'm conscious of time we have been
going for two hours now I am gonna have
a comfort break for us all but it is
strict two minutes because we are
flirting with our deadline so please two
minutes no longer
thank you
yeah
[Music]
all right
yes
so yeah
foreign
okay that the strict two minutes is up
so if I could please ever ask everyone
to take their seats as quickly as they
possibly can
yeah cancer curtains
now members uh well while we're all here
clap everyone's attention again please
ladies and gentlemen in the back if you
couldn't if you wouldn't mind ceasing
your conversations now while we can
reconvene
um members we have half an hour before
we have to take a vote on whether we
continue I'm very conscious of the fact
that we have two quite big applications
coming up I think it's probably worth us
taking that vote now
um so I'm going to assume oh I'm going
to propose that we continue past the 8
30 deadline
um so that we can hear particularly the
two larger items could I have someone
second that please thank you and could
have a show of hands to those in favor
of going past that time
lovely that's that's unanimous lovely
thank you thank that's a big relief
um okay so our next
item is um planning effort
and our presenting officer is Amy flutes
Amy whenever you're ready over to you
thank you chairman the site denoted by
the black dot is within the built-up
area boundary for stratford-upon-avon
the application site edged red is part
of The KES playing field the site
adjoins Manor Road a residential street
there are TPO trees which form part of a
wider group TPO to the site's western
boundary
a grade two listed Sports Pavilion is to
the southeast of the site within the
playing field and planning permission is
sought for the erection of six dwellings
and two vehicular access points
the site plan on the left indicates the
proposed layout dismissed at appeal by
application
2000-9874 the inspector dismissed the
scheme due to the impact on neighboring
immunity and the impact on trees covered
by a TPO
the site plan on the right is the site
plan for consideration as part of this
application the layout has been revised
and all the trees are to be retained on
site
there are two house house types proposed
four of the units will be house type A
which can now be seen and these are four
bed dwellings
and two of the units will be house type
B again four bed dwellings both house
types will be constructed from brick
clay roof tiles and aluminum windows
this image is taken from Manor Road
looking into the application site in an
easterly Direction you can see the
sports field and the houses which are
join the perimeter
this image shows the site's Northern
boundary and the nearest adjoining
property Globe Cottage the trees which
form part of the group TPO can also be
seen
this image is looking into the site in a
self-eastly direction the grade 2 listed
Pavilion is screened by the existing
trees and hopefully this Arrow will show
you the approximate location of it
um this image is taken from the playing
field looking towards the site in a
North Westerly Direction and the
approximate access locations can be seen
and now some images to demonstrate the
character of dwellings along Mana Road
chairman it is not considered that the
proposal will result in unacceptable
harm to Heritage assets trees subject to
a TPO landscape neighboring immunity
highways or flood risk the
recommendation is to Grant the
application subject to conditions and
notes and subject to completion of an
agreeable unilateral undertaking as
detailed within the committee report
please note an update on the update
sheet and just one verbal update the
bottom of page 60 should read The
Proposal is considered to be sensitive
and safe and Accords with policy thank
you
me thank you very much indeed let's call
our first speaker on this item who is
councilor Ian fraggley of Stratford
employment Town Council
good evening councilor fragile thank you
for your patience
and while you're getting yourself
settled I just remind you you'll have
three minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning and once you are settled and
your microphone is on the floor is yours
thank you chair
Stratford Town Council acknowledges the
built-up area of Stratford town on the
provider that there are plenty of green
and opal spaces also provided amongst
the housing
and there is no doubt that manner rode
with homes on the North side and
tree-lined Fields on the south side is
one of the finest examples of this
within the built up areas of Stratford
which no doubt this committee have also
experienced if they've made a a site
visit
I anticipate other speakers this evening
will cover the pros and cons of this
application so the Town Council would
like to concentrate on the aspect of the
wonderful rows of trees involved
that there has already been an example
set south of the river regarding trees
and hedges in this situation being on
the west side of Kipling Road in which
the trees and hedges were similarly to
remain in place during construction and
perpetuity when the poppy Meadow
development was being proposed and
developed on the fields opposite
side of Kipling Road
if this committee is inclined to accept
the planning office's decision proposal
then the Town Council would request that
a condition is applied to safeguard all
the excess increase facing Manor Road
and the route protection zones of all
these trees
such that of the proposed building plots
such that none of the proposed building
plots nor proposed internal roads on the
site encroach onto the root protection
zones of the trees
and during the development phase no
delivery vehicles site workers vehicles
and storage of materials should encroach
onto the route protection zones of the
trees thank you
thank you very much members do we have
any questions for Council of frenchney
Council Crump
okay sorry um
you expressing concerns about protecting
the trees if we were minded to Grant is
that where you were sorry
I can't eat very well
um you you were my you're expressing
concerns about the protection of trees
from the plots if we were minded to
Grant it was that your your come down I
couldn't go out here as well so I think
these are Marco phones yes the talent
council is very uh
it it wants each party to know what they
can and cannot do the only way you can
start that up is by having it written
down uh there have been incidents in
this town and I'm not going to name
where where suddenly Hedges and trees
are taken down overnight
um and that's what we're trying to
protect
okay any other questions
no in that case counter strategy thank
you very much for your time and patience
okay let's move to our next speaker who
is the Mr David Neal
good evening Mr Hill again thank you
very much for your patience
[Music]
once you're settled and comfortable
you'll have three minutes again I'll
give you a 30 second warning if you stay
seated for questions afterwards that'd
be great press the button in the middle
it will go red and the floor is yours
however laudable the Ambitions of cares
to improve the sports field at Manor
Road it cannot be detriment to the
detriment of the Green Space policy in
the area section one five of the listed
building and conservation act 1990
States the cartilage of a building I.E
the principal building is in general
terms any area of land and other
buildings that are around and associated
with that principal building
this statement is confirmed in historic
England's listed building and cartilage
consultation draft 20 of the 27th of
January 2017 English Heritage historic
England further state that they remain
concerned by the potential damage by
development contrary to the established
planning policy put forward as a way of
benefiting significant places but
destroy more than they save
the policy that they use to determine
acceptability includes five criteria it
will not harm the Heritage value of the
place or setting enabling development is
a type of public subsidy and should be
subject to the same degree of financial
scrutiny scrutiny and transparency and
accountability as a cash Grant from
public sources Mr Sergeant Secretary of
State inspector in paragraph six of his
report concedes that Criterion 3 could
well be seen to conflict in reducing the
size of the adjacent pitches which would
need to be made smaller to compensate
for the loss of land and Criterion 4
which allows for the provision of land
at other schools to replace that which
is lost is ignored by kezi's application
kezov admitted to raising 4 million for
other school projects and we see no
reason why funds for this project cannot
be raised without the loss of this
Sports area which the expense inspector
acknowledged that little evidence to
support its position was evidenced or
extensive
the national policy planning framework
policy clw1 protecting and enhancing
existing Community facilities paragraphs
11 10 12 page 127 States outdoor
Community facilities including Playing
Fields sports facilities and other
recreational land will be protected
against the loss of encroachment no
reference to these policies was made by
the inspector
Stratford's core strategy in its long
time coming is not to be treated lightly
or thrown aside with enabling factors to
cross its path 30 seconds it is our
coherent system for planning the future
the core strategy for which councilors
have signed up States PCC com and PCC 17
development should protect and enhance
their natural built-in historic
environment in the assessment core
strategy on land Parcels for future
usage on the edge of Stratford Manor
Road is not on the list of
considerations the core strategy
acknowledges that the quality of life
should aim for a high quality
multifunctional green infrastructure Mr
Neil I'm afraid I'm going to have to ask
you to wrap up I'll give you a couple of
seconds you'll stop that's even better
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any
foreign
please
no
in that case Miss Nils thank you very
much for your time contribution
okay our next speaker's in this item are
Mr Frampton and Mr Carr good evening to
you both
[Music]
yeah
I'm so sorry this is
um so you'll have six minutes
um are you is it just yourself Mr car
that's going to be speaking for six
minutes are you splitting do you
understand the timings of your splits do
you want me to give you warnings we're
fine I think you're all well practiced
and reversed in this so okay in that
case I won't give you any warnings at
all until your six minutes is up and
then I'll I'll shut you down at that
point whenever you're ready the floor's
yours thank you very much chair
our long-standing aim is to create a
state-of-the-art sporting Hub with
Benefits split equally between the
school and the community the funds
released from this development which
lies outside the area used for sport
will allow desperately needed sports
facilities to be built
since first obtaining planning
permission for a flood-lit or weather
pitch in 2008 we've explored various
potential funding streams but
regrettably our efforts have been done
successful
without this proposed development there
is no reasonable chance that these
facilities will be realized in the
foreseeable future
to the schemes of flood-lit or weather
pitch for which Planning Commission has
already been granted this facility which
will primarily be used for hockey and
Tennis but can also be used for a
variety of sports including football
will mean that our teams will no longer
have to travel by minibus to solihull
every day to train and to play home
fixtures
the walkable facility at Manor Road will
therefore reduce travel costs and carbon
emissions but most importantly will
enable all of our students not just
those in teams to participate in hockey
and tennis
the new sports facilities enabled by the
development will also be of demonstrable
benefit to our Sports Club Partners in
the town being available for Community
use over 50 hours per week during term
time and over 80 hours per week during
the holidays
these facilities for example are
desperately needed by the growing
Stratford Hockey Club who play who are
currently playing home matches on a
weekly basis in Warwick and Stratford
Town Cults Stratford Town Colts football
club who are urgently need more floodlet
facilities for some with some of their
34 teams traveling as far afield as
Warwick University to train and play
as part of our plans the 1971 Sports
Pavilion will be restored and internally
modernized the outdated boys communal
changing and shower areas will be
replaced by four new men's and women's
changing rooms with individual shower
cubicles and accessible toilet
facilities as well as a first aid room
the plans include a new Access Road
leading to a 60 space car and Coach Park
which will significantly reduce local
congestion especially on weekend match
days
importantly the new road will also allow
disabled access to the Pavilion and
enable emergency vehicles to reach pitch
side which are not current which is not
currently possible in wet weather
we were pleased that the inspector
acknowledged the significant benefits
that our plans will have for the
community and the school and concluded
that with some adjustments there was no
reason the school the scheme could not
be delivered the revised plans aimed to
address directly the changes recommended
by the inspector and we hope that you'll
be able to accept your officer's
recommendation which in turn will enable
us to implement our ambitious plans to
provide sporting facilities that this
town and the schools so desperately need
and which has widespread public support
thank you uh there are those who
continue to hold a root and Branch
objection to the loss of effectively a
small peripheral area of the playing
fields to enable the provision of
enhanced sports facilities
for those who object at the recent
inspector's decision is a fundamental
consideration indeed the planning
practice guidance states that the
persistence by a local planning
Authority objecting to a scheme or
elements of a scheme which an inspector
has previously indicated to be
acceptable is an example of unreasonable
behavior the inspector has reached the
decision that the principle of this
development is acceptable he raised two
specific design concerns namely the
relationship of plot one to Glebe
Cottage and the loss of trees from the
TPO
the design the revised design comes in
this application these design concerns
have been satisfactorily addressed there
will be no loss of trees from this
scheme and in response to an earlier
question about trees
um during construction you'll note there
are shorthand conditions relating to a
construction management plan condition
three condition eight and agricultural
method statement and another condition
that requires the service runs to be
submitted to and approved by the LPA
in terms of the Heritage consideration
again that is a matter that was
addressed by the inspector paragraph 35
of his decision letter the experience of
the Pavilion would therefore not be
diminished so that
Specter has considered and considered
satisfactory he considered the principle
was satisfactory as I said he identified
two very specific design concerns which
have now been addressed thank you
thank you both well within your six
minutes members do we have any questions
for either our speakers cancer Parry
first
thank you and good evening gentlemen
um I just wondered whether you can
explain
um why your properties are based on four
bedrooms rather than three bedrooms
which would then conform to the SBD
parking regulations of Stratford
District Council
the issue here is clearly to raise
Finance in the development of a land to
enable the sports pitches and the
all-weather pitch and The Works to the
Pavilion to be
achieved by the revenue of that so it's
important that the value of that land is
maximized and it's an issue that again
the inspector considered and had no
issue with the size of dwellings that
were proposed for this application thank
you
anyone else have any questions they
would like to ask councilor Adam
thank you um with regards to the
all-weather pitch you're talking about
um presume that's been granted planning
permission already and just enlighten me
to when that was and how that process
came about at that time
2008 was the original permission
2016. there was a section 73 application
which uh granted permission with varied
conditions and that permission has been
lawfully implemented okay so and it
hasn't been constructed as of yet no no
this is the the whole Genesis of this
application is to provide the finance
because there is no other means of
financing the delivery of those Sports
pictures how is it that we're
70 years down the line before we're
seeing this application considering that
that was part of the court of funding it
then you might want to answer that but I
mean from my point we've obviously had
an appeal we've had a previous
application which was refused and then
we've had the inspector's decision but
the school was going through various
exercises to try and find the finance
from the Sports Council a lottery fund
Ben will extend that in terms of the
efforts that have gone through to try
and finance it other than this enabling
development
final question
um have you conducted a financial
viability assessment to back this up
more independently I'd say
is there
have our officers
so I don't think it's relevant to us how
these guys Finance their developments
what's relevant to us is what's put in
front of us in our planning policies I'm
going to ask you to retract that I'm
afraid okay
do we have any other questions
Council Crump
it's just to clarify last point and I
think Mr Frampton had Advanced it but
just to make sure so
other alternative sources of funding
have been exhausted
so therefore this is the way you're
going to fund the scheme about the
sports sports we're pushing the
boundaries of what we're missing to do
we we shouldn't be discussing finances
in public if you want to discuss the
finances in any great detail we have to
go into a closed session which means I'm
going to have to eject everybody in the
in the hall I don't think it's relevant
uh to our planning decision we're here
to make a decision on what's put in
front of us based on planning's
philosophy
okay do we have any other questions
no in that case both of you thank you
very much for your time contribution and
your patience
okay our final speaker on this item is
councilor Rolf councilor off you make
your way forward I think you understand
the drill five minutes 30 second warning
use as much or as little as five minutes
as you wish when you're ready and
comfortable to any microphone on the
floor is yours
foreign ly I would like to say that when
the inspector came to visit the site it
was during covid and there were no cars
parked along the road and secondly he
stated in his inspector's report that
the road is unlined this is wrong there
are double yellow lines along the road
opposite beach close making a third of
the road unpackable at any time and this
is very significant councilor Parry what
you asked earlier now to go through the
report cs-15 States on page 50 of the
report this site is not an allocated
site for residential development and it
is not in the NDP in fact the NDP goes
on to say that this area is the green
lung south of the river
cs15 also states that development is
expected to protect and enhance the
character this does neither it's a row
of boring looking modern houses set
within the cartilage of a grade 2 listed
building completely out of character
with the surrounding area these houses
will obscure the view to the listed
Pavilion for most residents page 51
policy cs-16 we have an over provision
of homes but the planner seems to say
that Stratford can accommodate a further
six dwellings why should we page 51
policy
cs25.2 there is no need and six houses
does not make a valuable contribution to
the character and Immunity page 52 sport
England have objected please read what
they say page 60 there is an under
provision of seven parking spaces we
have a clear policy on the number of
parking spaces each four bedroom house
should have three per house with visitor
parking why is this being ignored please
also note that there is a planning
permission for a further entrance down
the road causing a further loss of five
six spaces highways didn't take this
into account there could be a loss of 12
13 parking spaces in total this is
shocking and even more shocking that
highways didn't object I've already
stated that the inspector got it wrong
about the road being unlined when he
reviewed it County highways can get it
wrong as well
there is Saint Peter's mission on this
road which runs regularly community
activities where the where will the
users Park I've had a group coordinators
crying to me about having to close their
clubs if this application goes ahead the
vicar of avastin is seriously concerned
about the future of some of the
community activities run by the church
because of lack of parking at a recent
application in Warwick where highways
said parking was below standard but
shouldn't be too much of an issue the
planning committee listened to What the
residents said and took a brave decision
and turned the application down on
parking grounds please be brave this is
serious and now the trees the most
important visual aspect of Manor Road
with a wealth of TPO trees and again the
inspector read the report written by the
applicant and was satisfied that the
trees Will Survive really of course they
won't no amount of protection will stop
the constant use of Machinery vibrating
over the land slowly but surely damaging
the roots of the trees and the disregard
out of the builders we've all seen this
oh it won't be a problem attitude what
about the scaffolding and cranes with
the canopies of these beautiful trees
they or most of the trees will not
survive this Carnage and we've seen
Builders break the conditions and then
it's too late let's be brave we've had
years and years of cares putting in
applications for people of upped and
sold because they can't take the
constant harassment and uncertainty any
longer at amazing several years ago we
suggested to the head that we as a group
would help fundraise for their
reconfigurations of the land we could
have raised it by now and we wouldn't be
here fighting once again
they don't need a state-of-the-art rugby
pitch which the inspector agrees could
be smaller due to conflicting with
Criterion three bottom of page 53 the
Rugby Club less than 100 yards away of
proposals to put two full-size pitches
in on their land there will be no
benefits to the community as all use
will be restricted to when the school
aren't using it and and Charities and
Community groups will be charged you
know they can't give it for free no one
can
they receive over half a million pounds
yearly from the town trust no other
school in Stratford gets anything kez is
a privileged school they could raise the
money to do what they want without
building six hideous looking houses
spoiling everyone's Outlook and ruining
people's livelihoods in the process the
people living around the playing fields
have had enough
I don't mean to sound patronizing but
please be brave no two inspectors will
see the same issues or indeed come to
the same conclusion and the last one
didn't do a complete fact check either
the inspector got his facts wrong about
the lines on the road this is a very
very important issue this affects the
parking along all of this road and this
is a huge issue and can be dealt with as
a reason for refusal I urge you to
refuse this application thank you
come on
foreign
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for our award member
please
no looks like all bases covered cancer
off thank you very much for your time
contribution
okay let's move two points clarification
of our officers who would like to ask a
question Council Dixon first please
thank you chairman uh we heard from I
think it was uh Peter Frampton
um that uh the only aspects we really
ought to be perhaps considering are
those which the inspector Drew and gave
his reasons for the appeal failing and
therefore we are we only really to
consider the trees and the impact I
think it was plot one on the neighboring
property
um because I think that was the the
comment from the agent there uh if Amy
lat comment please
okay so um obviously um into terminate
in in the determination of the
application you have to consider all
everything
um which is a material planning
consideration
um the planning inspectors
um report
um is a material consideration in the
determination of the planning
application my officer report has gone
through
um The View and my view and then
obviously taking in consideration that
the points from the inspector and I have
come to the view in my office of
recommendation that
um the matters have have been addressed
as part of the resubmission of this
planning application which the inspector
dismissed the previous application on
yes I may follow up chairman
um because I think the agent was made
some reference to if we were to refuse
this and disagree with a comment on a
part of that inspector's report that
would be a justification for fees and
cost against us something like that
um as I said yesterday appeal decision
is a material consideration
um and it is um potential that if you
were to go against
um the views of the inspector it may
open up costs
um in the future I'll just see if Alice
has anything she'd like to add to that
point
thanks Amy yeah just just to reiterate
exactly what Amy said I think that the
thing to bear in mind is the inspector's
decision is a material planning
consideration that we have to have
regard to in the determination of the
application I think it's I think a part
of the PPG was referred to by the
applicant or their agent there in terms
of you know it being a potential grounds
for costs where an inspector has found a
matter to be acceptable if there hasn't
been any changes in the resubmission but
we determined to refuse and we could
potentially be in cost territory so I
think it is a fair thing to kind of warn
members that there is a danger of that
if you find things that are unacceptable
the inspector did consider to be
acceptable
cancer Parry
thank you chair
um could I just ask because I I haven't
seen the full
um appeal uh decision on this particular
application
um if the inspector made reference to
the parking SPD criteria
um and what weight
in terms of a policy of an approved
Stratford District Council policy that
has been through consultation should we
be giving to
okay let me just find the relevant part
of the inspector's decision
in the meantime while Amy's pulling that
up could I just come in please
of course you can I think something I'd
just like to clarify is that obviously
we do have the recommended parking
standards are set out in our SPD
um but I obviously um councilor Perry
referred to his policy strictly speaking
it's not policy it doesn't form part of
our core strategy policy is obviously
guidance it's contained within the SPD
which we have made and we've considered
and we've decided to adopt so it is
obviously a material planning
consideration but they are recommended
guidance rather than policy I just
wanted to make that point
thank you that's very helpful Amy
um I'm happy to read the paragraph from
the inspector's decision if that helps
um so it states and this is paragraph
41. the council also contended that each
house should have a minimum of free
on-site spaces plus a visitor space the
development falls short of this with
only 12 to be provided in total I
recognize that if demand reached the
level anticipated by the council this
could well result in parking being
displaced off-site however mindful of
the acknowledged capacity of Manor Road
to accommodate parked vehicles and
noting to the site's proximity to the
town center it has not been demonstrated
that this would impact highway safety
unacceptably
so does that answer your question
I think he probably does
okay do we have oh we do sorry uh
Council Cargill please thank you uh
right just picking up the point about
the trees and the tpos
ETC uh I'm assuming that you considered
this thoroughly about the protection of
those trees can you just explain what
protection measures you would be put in
place those
so a tree report has been submitted as
part of the application
um and um if I just go to different plan
um so one of the recommended conditions
is that the development is carried out
in accordance with the tree report and
some of these plans are from the tree
report which indicates that
um there's going to be
um protective fencing barrier in two
different
maybe cell web and root bridge to
protect the root protection areas where
there is some incursion into the root
protection areas of those TPO trees
um the report also states that um one
limb of t13 is to be removed and that
there would also be some Crown lifting
to T6 T10 and t11 so obviously that tree
report would be conditioned and they'd
have to carry out the development in
accordance with that in addition the
tree report states that a condition
should also be provided for an arbor
cultural method statement so that we can
pin down that finer detail and that is
another condition which is recommended
in addition a condition for service runs
so that we can be satisfied where the
services are going to be going to make
sure that they don't unacceptably harm
the trees any further
Council Foreman please thank you just
going back to parking again sorry but
councilor Rolfe said in us when she gave
her a talk that um there were double
yellow lines on Manor Road that the
inspector hadn't mentioned in his report
is that the case or not um I've just had
a quick
um glance over the section of the report
and I'm just going to ask councilor
Richards if he will too because I
couldn't see anything to that effect but
that could just be me reading it quickly
so if that's okay yeah bear with me okay
Council Ralph Council Rolf please don't
shout out particularly when I'm trying
to read and obser
absorb evidence we will come to you in
just a moment
I'm hope hopefully this is going to help
um the inspector doesn't refer to any
double yellow lines along the road what
he does refer to is his observation and
I will read you his observation when I
visited some cars were parked along the
east side of Manor Road by the
application site although there was
still space for more Vehicles so clearly
he's observed cars parked along that
road albeit the east side of it I'm only
gonna I'm going to assume and this is an
assumption not an absolute I'm going to
assume he is referring to the side
opposite uh this site
so if you're yeah if you're looking out
it's on the other side
um that's as good as I can give you
really he doesn't specifically refer to
double yellow speed does refer to cars
being parked along that Eastern side of
Mana Road okay so but we we don't know
for a fact if there are double yellow
lines or not or how far they are or
um I I went to
um to cite um I just drove by earlier
this morning and there are some double
yellow lines as you enter Manor Road
um and and obviously I was I was driving
so I don't know the exact positionings
um but as you travel further north along
Manor Road the double yellows do then
stop and then you can freely Park on on
the
um Eastern side of the carriageway I
didn't check on what the line situation
was um while I was there but that was
just my driving observation as I was
driving down the road
um I'm so just to be clear that I'm not
presenting this as evidence I'm just
giving you an observation again I've got
the Google Map open now at the precise
site here I can't see evidence of yellow
lines what I can see is cars parked on
both sides of the road
um but clearly it's for you to decide
and discern from the information you've
been given what you believe to be
correct
okay just uh bear with me councilor
Parry um councilor off before you jump
in you have a right for points of
um uh point of order
is yours a point of order
okay if you'd like to come forward
[Music]
actually it's two points of order the
first point of order is that it was
actually the Mr Frampton's report that
said there were no lines on the road I
can absolutely guarantee there are lines
on the road as the county councilor I
had them put in because people from
beach close could not exit or go into
their own Road and there are double
yellow lines along the Eastern side okay
because that wasn't a point of order
that was a statement of fact which I'm
quite happy for you to give now but yeah
we'll leave it at that I think for the
timing
Council Dixon was next
thank you chairman I don't know if it
has any relevance or not
um I was just looking at page 60 where
Amy's report the site is not within the
town boundary that did surprise me when
I read that is that of any importance at
all so that's reference to part o of the
development requirements SPD which sets
out um the areas of parking distribution
um for Stratford So within the Town
Center boundary for Stratford it has a
lesser parking requirement than what the
rest of Stratford does that's outside of
that boundary so hopefully that
clarifies that point
so it's okay
you should check your microphones off
please cancel Crump
very briefly
um if I heard Amy correct the the
planning inspector
said
the Reliance on rsbd for three parking
spaces for four bedroom properties
wasn't particularly
strong or relevant because there was a
sufficient parking in Manor Road and
elsewhere is that correct and if that is
the case would that have been since
checked by the County Council in their
response back to us
so the the
answer was satisfied that the level of
provision that has been provided is
acceptable
um in terms of the response um from
highways um I can if you if you just
give me two seconds I can I can get that
up and just have a look to see if they
made reference
So within
um the no objection from highways they
have stated
the applicant acknowledges that the
proposed on-site parking for two parking
spaces per dwelling is below that set
out in the SDC SPD however they note
that this matter was fully reviewed by
the planning inspector in the previous
appeal decision at paragraphs 41-42 who
concluded that whilst the parking
proposals fell short of SPD levels this
would not lead to demonstrable or
unacceptable harm to highway safety the
highway Authority note that the Quantum
of on-site parking has been considered
acceptable by the planning inspectorate
as such it is acknowledged that an
objection based on insufficient on-site
parking causing unacceptable harm to
highway safety would be very unlikely to
be sustained does that help that is very
helpful thank you
councilor Parry
thank you chair
um councilor Rolfe made reference to
when the inspector visited the site
being during covid and I note the appeal
was refused on the 20th November 2020
um obviously During the period of covid
many sort of clubs and that sort of
thing were doing
um activities via zoom and people not
going and mixing so much
um
I'm just interested to know whether
there was whether you had any indication
of the date of when the inspector
actually visited the site and where the
Council of Roth is correct in her
presentation of saying it was during
covert which obviously would explain why
there were not so many parked cars in
Manor Road at that time
the question because the appeal decision
states that the site visit was made on
the 5th of July 2021
my birthday
councilor Adam did you signal
thank you um thanks
um
amongst the highways aspects in terms of
parking what seems to be accepted by the
um appeal and then highways as a result
is that there's no detriment to highway
safety is there another metric by which
we determine parking to be acceptable or
unacceptable outside of being safety
like congestion
right for example
sort of it might not cause highway
safety but it might be a detriment to
the residential immunity type of thing
do you see what I mean
um so obviously highways have
um reviewed the proposal from a highway
safety point of view and they are happy
in terms of
um
an amenity point of view
um as an officer I'm satisfied that that
there is sufficient provision and it
wouldn't cause unacceptable harm the
inspector does make reference to um
light light glare from Vehicles into the
neighboring properties and the inspector
did find that that wouldn't be
unacceptable so that may help
to some extent
okay have we got any more points of
clarification no in that case let's move
into debates who's going to kick us off
pointy fingers coming out cancer Kendall
okay thank you for pointing at me
chairman um right I can certainly
understand why residents are keen on
this
but we've gone around the houses and I'm
afraid at the end of the day I just
cannot see
substantial grounds to go against this
it's been seen by a by an inspector
already who's
and we do have to take that into account
I think it's Council Dixon who said you
know talking about costs we can't keep
sending this back to a you know trying
to appeal to an inspector
I can't see a reason to go against it so
I'm happy to propose we Grant
thank you very much Council Cargill
thank you chair
um
the officer has said that we can't
actually consider all elements of the
report and therefore what considering
the inspectors comments we can offer our
own options
um right the reason is to be given by an
applicant a laudable the May the sports
are vital to the health outcomes of our
youth of our area the scheme will
provide much needed funds so I'm not
opposed in principle to the development
but I do have concerns over the
buildings
I feel personally that the site is over
developed and has an overbearing nature
due to the size and bulk of the
buildings these are the the local
streets scene which are obviously
significantly smaller than that
single dwelling they're single story
the plan demonstrates the insufficient
car parking spaces which is against
guidance and I feel I should mention
that we've been fought in those
conditions for some time now on many
planning applications so I don't see why
it should be different here
there is a 10-year housing land Supply
this is not local need and in my mind
it's therefore failed to demonstrate
need
I noticed an interesting one on the
immunity space
it says although that there's a view of
Open Fields from properties three to six
it does not uh and does not create
overlooking but does not equate in my
mind to the required 10.5 meters of
actual immunity space that can be
physically used it seems that it could
be argued that no Gardens are needed if
you can see a field from them
uh Sports England have robustly objected
to the scheme and it fails to meet any
of the criteria E1 to E5 concerns
obviously over drainage of the site
though that can be
um conditioned as always there is
planning balance but I feel there is a
sufficient justification of what I've
just said to go oppose granting plan
permission
cheers so I'm clear are you proposing a
refusal yes yes thank you very much
Council Dixon please
thank you chairman uh I support
councilor Kendall's View and I will
second his proposal to Grant
thank you very much anyone else wants
coming Council Parry
[Music]
always one to come and make a difference
um I'd like to support councilor
cargill's proposal I have great issues
because of the parking situation how
often are we sat around this committee
we are refusing
um applications for four bedroom houses
because we haven't got sufficient
parking in front now I take note that of
the inspectors comments
um and the reason for dismissal
but there were in my view there are
extenuating
circumstances here
um as someone who uses Mana Road on a
regular basis
um and even had um
my daughter's third birthday party at
Saint Peter's Mission I can assure you
the amount of events that are held at
the Fantastic facility is even hard to
park in the current circumstances when
there's an event going on there
I do think we need to stand by our
guidelines and have consistency across
all applications and it is in my view
this this application if it came back
as an application for six three bedroom
houses I wouldn't have an objection
because it would not violate the SBD
parking guidelines and it wouldn't be
over development of the site because
there would be it would be more balanced
in my view with the properties in Manor
Road so on that basis I will be
supporting councilor cargill's refusal
I'm going to assume that's a a formal
seconding of thank you anyone else like
to speak at this point in the debate
counts the Crump
it looks like I'm
um in between two people who are opposed
to me today
um
I will be supporting the application
I've got concerns about going against
the planning inspector and we've been
told by the planning manager that their
decision holds material weight
we've not had any objection on terms of
road safety and parking from the
highways Authority who are the lead
Authority on parking
and
um again I
I've I think some of the applications
what it's been done which I've been told
are you know I can understand what it's
been done and what's been used to the
fund and I've I've got sympathy there so
I won't go on to that so
I think each side is different so
therefore
it's yeah eat a bit professional each
each site is different I certainly do
agree with it
as long as you I think it's difficult
and we talk about consistency we had
something on the previous application on
the application before regarding our
bins and uh 25 meters or 30 meters and
then we then we went to 70 meters so so
we're not consistent so therefore
I will be supporting the officer's
recommendation to Grant because I think
that the decision made by the planning
cons inspector holds material and
significant weight
thank you very much anyone else wish to
contribute before we moved to a vote no
okay so we have two proposals both of
which have been seconded again um the
first is to Grant uh proposed by cancer
Kendall secondly by councilor Dixon we
must take that first and then we will
take the second if we need to get that
far so proposal is to Grant in line with
the officer recommendation can I please
have show hands for those in favor of
Grant
one two
five and those against
one two three four five six
okay so that therefore fails so we now
have proposal to refuse um the reasons
that councilor Cargill gave I believe uh
Street Scene over development of sight
uh contrary to our parking SPD
um and not identified as a local lead is
that correct and by bulk I think that
fits in with over development
is there anything else you want to add
to it you're happy
um seconded by uh councilor Parry I
believe um there's nothing else you want
to add at this point okay could I please
have a show of hands for those in favor
of refusing for the reasons that have
been given
one two
one two three five six and those against
one two three four five
okay committee therefore resolves two
refuse application twenty one zero four
zero zero six seven
[Applause]
okay we'll very quickly move into our
next application which is application
reference 21040 I'm sorry
excuse me bear with me
Alice do you want to come in yes please
I just need to clarify the reasons for
refusal I know okay just vote sorry
Alice just bear with me because the
people are moving so we'll just take two
seconds and I'll I'll come back to you
thank you
okay if we could just settle down again
please I think most people have now made
their way out now we just um uh our
planning manager has just asked for
clarification on a couple of things I
think you said on the reasons for
refusal Alice is that right yeah so just
to uh I've wrote them down and I've put
my paper in the wrong place hang on
I think from my side if I tell you what
I heard and then I can just check that
that corresponds with with what the the
decision was you can yeah you might have
to speak up a bit because for some
reason you're a bit quieter than you
were 10 minutes ago I don't usually get
that criticism okay so um the the things
that I um picked up from cancer Cargill
was over development of the site and
overbearing to the street scene being
much larger than what's around it so I
think that's kind of a a cs9 design
reason
um I then also wrote down that there was
obviously insufficient parking
um doesn't comply with the guidance set
out in the SPD so that would be a cs26
reason so that's two reasons
and then a couple of other things which
were put out there was insufficient
amenity space a robust objection from
Sports England and in the not being a
local need
I'm a bit concerned about those reasons
for the reason set out in the report in
terms of yes the lengths aren't there
but they do the areas do comply in
Garden terms to the SPD so that's in
terms of the insufficient immunity space
point
that wasn't discussed as part of the
vote the vote was on streets you know
development uh scale and bulk car
parking and no local need I'm entirely
happy that those are in place um the two
others that you refer to the sport
England and the immunity space weren't
included okay so in terms of no local
needs so what would be the policy hook
for that reason for refusal
simply no identified local need
[Music]
um
it hasn't been put forward as a local
needs scheme so I think we know we're
it's a bit tricky to say that it doesn't
comply with the local need because
they're not asking for that that type of
development
um
um Alice perhaps so I understand your
point
um I think this is we we've obviously
we've discussed these and we've taken a
vote already and I'm not going to go
back through all that most people have
already gone
um and uh our members are here we've
made the decision based on those four
criteria the wording of which is as
usuals
outside of this meeting agree the
wording and then I can confirm that with
the proposal and the second day before
we move forward with it
I think that's the most logical thing to
do
thank you for bringing it out
um right sorry
let's try again
oh it's been so straightforward tonight
hasn't it
um okay so our next item is application
reference 2200748 very that's land off
Banbury Road in puritan priors
opportunity to officer is Paul Thompson
and as soon as he is set up ready to go
let's open to him
beg you pardon
update sheet
uh yeah I mistyped the application
number on the in the report so that's
been corrected on the update sheet and
secondly we had a committee site visit
this afternoon uh councilor Richard's
chair and uh councilor Dixon and I were
in attendance with the three Neighbors
uh piloton prize we're on the Banbury
Road uh Main Road through the village
and
this is a slightly a bit more detail the
red buildings are listed buildings
they're they're not affected by this
proposal directly uh green lines are
public rights away likewise unaffected
uh so we're talking about three
applications rather than one helpfully
um nothing like a nice simple one to end
on
uh the first one was granted permission
in 2019 it's the one on screen now
um things to take note of two parking
spaces to the right visibility displays
here
and the distance between the front
elevation of the house and what I've
taken as my reference point is the the
fence post at the corner of the
neighboring Garden that distance being
5.3 meters see also the position of the
Hedge these things will become important
uh this is how the house itself looked
uh when we granted permission for it
uh 9.7 meters to top the chimney uh I
must stress here that these are the
measurements on the plans you may hear
others this evening
9.7 meters the top of the chimney eight
meters to the ridge line and 5.5 meters
to the lower Ridge line on on the left
there uh you will know there is no
second floor there are no roof lights
that changes here this is the
application that we refused last year in
2021
uh you'll note here three parking spaces
uh you'll know also that the Hedge has
moved forwards from the uh the fence
post there and you'll note also that the
house has moved forwards a similar sort
of distance 3.6 meters now being the
distance from down from Five Point
whatever I said three
um reason for those three parking spaces
helpfully indicate with a big red circle
is that we now have a second floor with
two bedrooms in it that brings the total
of bedrooms to five uh that means we
need three parking spaces
um
we'll you'll also see that whilst the
chimney has come down from 9.7 to 9.3
meters uh the ridge line the ridge
Line's plural have gone up to 8.4 and
5.9 that's an increase on the plan of
about not between 0.4 and 0.5 meters
depending on how you you uh ground it uh
you'll see also some roof lights to
facilitate those bedrooms in the rear
roof uh slope there are some other
changes there's the there's this uh
chimney breast which is now external on
the side elevation
um and I think everybody would agree
that the remaining changes to window
Arrangements on the front and on the
rear pretty uncontroversial
um the main issue in this application
was the parking
to the front
um the county highways engineer
concluded that the uh there was no way
basically you could park three decently
sized vehicles on the the space that was
left after the dwelling had come forward
without some really awkward Maneuvers
that would have involved knocking into
the house into the hedge or reversing in
the road and causing a pileup
so
that was the reason for refusal the case
officer at the time concluded that the
impact on labor immunity low character
and distinctiveness all the other um
things we take into account was
acceptable
moving on to the current application
you'll note the site plans the same
nothing has changed there and we're now
down to two parking spaces again that's
because top floor bedrooms are gone it's
now a storage area the rear roof slope
this roof lights have gone they've been
tiled over
um the the other changes that were
proposed last year they're remaining
basically so Highway County highways has
requested a road safety audit receiver
road safety audit determined that that
was acceptable and they've withdrawn
their objections so the the only reason
for refusal was highways as I say that
is now no objection for that and so that
is where we are this is the house from
the front
this is from the garden of
brookhouse from my head to the uh East
and finally from the garden of one
um forgive me
um the house to the West anyway uh
looking side onto it with cul-de-sac and
whatever it's called see my report read
it
um my recommendation is to Grant
permission for the reasons they're in uh
the parish council disagree that's why
we're here thank you chair
okay thank you very much Paul that's
called our first Speaker of this item
who is councilor Ian Greenhall chairman
of person prize Parish Council
good evening and welcome good evening I
think you've got gist of what's going to
happen you've got three minutes I'll
give you 30 second warning before your
time is up otherwise whenever you're
ready and your microphone is on the
floor is yours please merch The Purge
Council object this application we
support democracy and when the original
application was approved by just one
vote at its third committee meeting we
respected that decision however it soon
became clear that what was being
constructed was not to the approved
plans so along with residents we raise
concerns with enforcement who confirmed
things were not correct
at this point most Builders would stop
and correct their error not in this case
and the bill continued to completion
without appropriate planning permission
or any dialogue between the developer
and Parish Council
every aspect apart from the size of the
building
borders on minimal standards on plot
density separation to neighboring
properties parking etc
etc
the officer saves the space between the
new house and one home stores is 13.6
meters and policy states a minimal gap
of 13 meters
however he then goes on to say the
chimney reduces the Gap by 0.5 meters
so now we have a gap of 13.1 meters just
10 centimeters above minimum in reality
it's actually 12.2 if you measure it
is important that these distances are
seen in the context of our village
generally
a gap of 13 meter separation might be
fine as a general policy for a new
housing estate where everyone knows what
they're getting when they buy their
house
this needs to be viewed and assessed for
each location
in our historic well-established Village
gaps are much bigger than that our
Parish plan survey highlighted the
things residents value with space
between properties and space around the
village being mentioned many times
the lack of separation is compounded by
the overbearing roof height being at
least half a meter higher than the
approved application
you notice there are no floor plans
showing the additional bedrooms and
ensuite in the roof space that was
previously refused
you can call it a three-bedroom house to
reduce the number of parking spaces you
can add conditions to remove permitted
development
but there is no way to enforce the
number of rooms being used a number of
people and vehicles
taking overall this is a proposal which
is out of character for our village goes
against our approved Parish plan and
will have a detrimental impact on the
private immediate of the residents at
number one home stores Meadow and others
Duff's Estates how the council cannot
monitor developments and his statement
sets a very dangerous precedent that
developers can build whatever they want
with minimal planning approval 30
seconds this developer has done exactly
that and we are left to suffer the
consequences when he walks away with his
profit we urge you to refuse this
application
foreign
at what point did you uh were you aware
that it was the roof was going higher
and there was another floor and did you
at that point
uh uh go to enforcement at The District
Council
enforcement have been involved quite a
few occasions we initially noted the
footings were further forward than they
should have been
then it gradually went up further
and then it was obvious when we saw
skylights appear
enforcement we keep on to them
and our local Ward member will know
we've been on to them
any other questions members
no council green on thank you very much
indeed for your time and your patience
this evening okay our next speaker on
this item is a Mr Derek Diggory
good evening mystery and welcome
pleasure now you'll have three minutes
again I'll give you a 30 second warning
when you're sat ready and comfortable if
you press the button in the middle it'll
turn your microphone on should go red
and then the floor will be yours
thank you
I am here to represent the residents of
the neighboring properties we wish to
highlight the numerous planning breaches
made by the Builder and to express our
disappointment with many of the
decisions made by the planning team
the initial application was made in 2018
and withdrawn on the advice of the case
officer who had concerns relating to the
height massing and separation between
the proposed property and those adjacent
we believe that the planning procedure
would be fair and impartial to all
parties we have found however that after
the submission of several retrospective
applications planning and enforcement of
continually found in favor of the
Builder a new application was made and
approved by the planning committee in
2019 all Beed with a greater mass and
height than the one that had been
withdrawn
the permission given was for the
construction of a three-bedroom 19th
century Cottage star dwelling very
quickly we realized that the Builder had
no intention of following the approved
plan and he proceeded to build a
three-story five-bedroom home
unfortunately planning were both
notified and as a result further
retrospective application was made
the Builder's agent claimed that the
reason for so many breaches was that the
Builder had misunderstood
the approved permission and also used
the wrong plans this execute would be
quite laughable with it not so serious
the new dwelling was cited two meters
forward from the agreed position the
roof fight had been increased by 0.55
meters this was done so the Builder
could add an extra floor to accommodate
two additional bedrooms and an ensuite
bathroom the chimney was built
externally instead of internally five
roof lights were installed Etc we
believe that with so many changes
planning and enforcement would take some
strong action this was however not
forthcoming and the Builder continued to
ignore the restrictions with seeming
impunity one of our major concerns now
is the completed Rue fight in the
withdrawal withdrawn application it was
deemed too high at 7.25 meters the
approved plan is 7.85 meters the
finished building has a supposed House
of 8.4 meters in fact we estimate that
at 8.7 meters
at the very least we would like to say
enforcement make the bill to reduce the
roof height to a level that corresponds
to the agreed plan
this is an opportunity for the planning
committee to show that developers cannot
take advantage of their planning
approvals and it would act as a warning
to those wishing to flout the rules
my final thought is to emphasize what
the department for communities and local
governments say about retrospective
plans and I quote these are primarily
intended for those who have made a
genuine mistake and wish to rectify and
legitimize that mistake it concludes by
saying that an authorized development is
unacceptable and unfair to the majority
who abide by the rules we residents are
abiding by the rules so I would ask all
of you ladies and gentlemen I appeal to
you your sense of fair-mindedness and
trust it will come to the correct
decision and refuse this application
thank you very much Mr degree thank you
very much indeed members do we have any
questions
do we have any questions for Mr degree
no Mr degree thank you very much for
your time and contribution and your
patience this evening
okay let's move to our next speaker who
is Miranda Rogers good evening and
welcome thank you for your patience
uh Mr Rogers you've been here many times
before you know the drill you actually
have six minutes today rather than three
so um use as much as it as you like
whenever you're comfortable the
microphone's on the floor is yours good
evening you have heard from the previous
speakers that there are many objections
to the application before you it is
regrettable that errors have been made
but as your officer's report States the
developers conduct or intentions and the
council's handling of previous
applications are not directly relevant
to the determination of the application
so the starting point in considering
this proposal is to acknowledge that
planning permission has been granted at
committee for the erection of a
three-bedroomed house in 2019.
if the application was put to you today
in its original approved format the
result should be the same there's been
no change in policy since the original
determination and there are no material
considerations which would indicate an
alternative decision should be taken
since then you've had two almost
identical very applications to
regularize the changes that have been
made through the build process
the changes made were in the main of
limited significance they are summarized
on your officer's report and I'm not
going to go through them again
the reasons why the changes were made
are not really relevant
so the first application very
applications refused in February this
year for highway safety reasons only the
as built property as you heard increased
the reach by half a meter thus provided
five rather than three bedrooms three
bedrooms meet the requirement for two
car parking spaces increasing number of
bedrooms to four and you need an extra
space County highways stated the site
could accommodate three parking spaces
without hitting the building with which
we didn't agree but anyway and as such
concluded the scheme would have an
unacceptable highway safety impact on
all other matters including impact on
the street scene and on labor immunity
the scheme was deemed acceptable there
were no reasons for refusal or anything
other than highways
the matter was referred to your
enforcement team who in an email to the
owner said you're not going to like this
remove the roof lights return the
property to three bedrooms and we'll be
happy
so the owner did that he took the roof
lights out he's tiled over them they
don't exist anymore it's an attic space
it's got no bathroom it's got no water
connections it's got no heating it's
just like the attic space and an awful
lot of houses which will probably be
filled with Christmas decorations
the removal of the attic bedrooms
Returns the house to three beds and a
requirement for two parking spaces
a swept path analysis of the site was
done by David Tucker Associates it
showed that two mpvs seven-seater
vehicles can enter Park and exit in a
forward gear the scheme therefore
complied with your development required
requirements SPD this was deemed to
overcome the single previous reason for
refusal and a revised vary application
was submitted which is now before you
the house now proposed in terms of size
position and appearance is identical to
that considered acceptable by your
offices in February the only physical
difference is that the roof lights have
been removed and internally the property
now provides three bedrooms
your office's report undertakes a
detailed analysis of the scheme taking
into account the fallback position of
the scheme approved in 2019 which would
still be approved today it acknowledges
the concerns of local people and the
parish council but concludes as did the
refused application that the scheme will
not have an adverse impact on labor
immunity or on the wider character and
appearance of the locality all the
relevant standards set out in your
developer requirements SBD are met and
Visually the property respects and
reflects the immediate locality the
heights of the nearest properties and
the setback within the street scene
highways was the only issue for the
first very scheme and at the request of
the County Council an independent road
safety audit was prepared with the
County Council witnessing two mpvs
entering parking and exiting at a
forward gear no adverse impact was
identified and County highways was able
to withdraw their objection
there can now be no substantiated
objection to the proposal on highways
grounds
so to summarize principal of the
three-bed dwelling established by grant
for planning permission in 2019 highway
safety previous objections clearly
overcome by a stage 3 safety audit and
Witnesses neighbor immunity this is the
same scheme that was considered in
February 2022 that was refused solely on
highways grounds there is little
difference from the approved skin in
2019 and all of the council's SPD
standards for immunity and privacy are
respected character the dwelling is
little different to that previously
approved it's identical to that which
was confirmed to be policy compliant in
February 2022. taking these points
together the proposal Accords entirely
with the development plan there are no
material considerations which indicate
an alternative decision should be
reached and as such I would ask that
you're Now Grant planning permission
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for Ms Rogers
no I have one if I may
um I went to the site visits today
um uh and made my own observations about
various things the visibility displays
do you currently have sufficient
visibility splay and if you don't do you
need to do work on either trees or
bushes or hedges in order to achieve
that yes there is sufficient visibility
display
okay that's right thank you very much
it's County Council would object thank
you very much
okay
um we will call our next speaker of the
uh for this item our last speaker of the
evening who is cancer O'Donnell
good evening and welcome thank you for
your patience um I think you know the
drill you'll have five minutes I'll give
you a 30 second warning before your time
is up otherwise whenever you're ready
thank you
um good evening committee I'd first
would like to start by thanking Paul and
Alice for the patience and compassionate
approach to this
application which has been really
difficult to navigate for the local
residents of piloton priors and um it's
a shame that we have not heard from the
developer or their agent at any point as
either a ward member or as a parish
council and just for correction the
visibility splays are hedges owned by
WCC and therefore you cannot guarantee
there'll be a timely trimming of those
in order to maintain the visibility
splays
you'll also be aware that Michael Gove
MP has stated that unauthorized
development is unacceptable and unfair
to the majority who abide by the rules
and you'll no doubt also be fully
briefed on the February 22 case in
Warsaw where Warsaw Council actually
ordered the demolition of an
unauthorized scheme because it did not
reflect the specific planning permission
that had been granted
you have already heard the details and
concerns raised by residents in the
parish council so I don't need to
revisit the increased height of the
building the insertion of first floor
windows and roof lights which are merely
tiled over not completely removed at
this point and the alteration to the
layout of the site including the
reposition of the house a whole two
meters in front of what was granted when
considering this case I'd ask you to
consider how your Wards would actually
react to this in piloton priors this has
caused huge unrest amongst our local
community it raises local residents
concerns regarding the teeth of
enforcement the strength of the role of
a parish council which we know is really
valuable and the true ability of our
planning team to oversee and advise you
planning applications from start and
vision to actual completion it's pretty
galling that the original planning
application was not in agreement with
the parish plan or the local needs
housing needs survey which is
specifically specified smaller
properties are required not the five
bedroom one that was put in and I recall
that planning meeting the original
scheme was passed by one vote at that
meeting councilor kettel asked if Gates
were needed to protect animals and
children who may run out onto the road
because the property was going to be so
close to a very busy road well it's now
a whole two meters closer it may have
passed a road safety audit stage three
but that relies as I've mentioned on
watch County Council trimming in a
timely fashion which may not always be
possible
um there are Justified concerns that
unless you actually remove the extra
roof space and remove the roof lights
rather than really tiling over them and
the reported stairs which is accessed to
those extra rooms there is always the
extra the X the risk rather of the extra
two bedrooms reappearing and I refer
back to Warsaw where the council leader
specified anyone who doesn't build
within the permission they will have
been granted will feel the full force of
planning enforcement with the support of
the courts if necessary we take direct
action against people who build
something outside the permission they
have been granted
for us as a district this development
could signal a really dangerous
precedent by there being no consequences
for applying for a three-bedroom
building a five bed with ensuite by
picking a footprint for a property then
moving it two meters close to the road
by raising the roof height and blocking
out all natural daylight to a neighbor
for the true extent of this not to be
punished in some way I fear is placing a
stake in the ground and Advising all
other small developers who fancy their
luck but the wild West have built
whatever you fancy is open and ready for
them to ride a rough shot over local
Parish plans and any advice from the SDC
planning team and for the industrial
enforcement simply don't worry so
therefore I urge you as a committee to
utilize your extensive expertise and
send a signal loud and clear that rules
are there to protect our local
communities and they are strictly
adhered to and respected and highly
relevant at Stratford District Council
thank you
foreign
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for our Ward member
councilor Crump first
I've got two well one's the same um
one's question one might be a broader an
honor statement question
um I'm concerned about
um
the comments about the visibility
supplies Council O'Donnell we've had
something in the report that the initial
rejection objection from the county has
been removed
um and the agent has said the visibility
the displays have been agreed
um so therefore without any evidence
I can't see how we can contradict that
they've got these visibility supplies
agreed so you comment on that and my
other comment is I'm concerned about
when I hear a statement which says
punish
we're not here to punish we're here to
make the decision on what's in front of
us and make it on planning rules and
requirements not here to punish we might
not agree with what's been done but we
have to follow the policy so apologies
if that's not a question
would you like me to respond to that
is that a question or a statement if I
change that punish to protect thank you
councilor Donald
I'm not sure that was a question I was
trying to understand what the question
was this is a cancer cramp wait
this is a opportunity for us to ask
questions not to make political
statements or other statements I'm not
saying that was a political one it was a
statement if you've got a question I'm
happy for you to ask a question
but if you if you haven't then we'll
move on I will ask the question do you
think we should be here to make
decisions on what's in front of us
based on planning applications rather
than a desire to punish alleged breaches
let's change let's let's play semantics
and change punish to protect we need to
protect our local residents when there
are planning applications that have been
granted and then you change them
willy-nilly without actually
engaging with your local communities and
without actually respecting the planning
procedure we are here at an extra
application because the applicant did
not respect what had already been
granted in the planning permission so
let's play semantics and change punish
to protect does that answer your
question
I think we're going to leave it at that
Council Rolf
um thank you councilor I I
think very carefully to what you said
because
um about a year ago I had something very
similar so uh what I want to ask you is
um
what solution do you as the ward member
are representing uh your residence
around what solution would you like to
see
come out of this what what is it yeah
um we're not here I'm sorry but we're
not here to look at Solutions we're here
to consider what is put in front of us
um so I'm not going to allow that okay
question to be asked if you've got a
different question by all means ask it
no thank you Council Cargill
that's what we've done the agent
mentioned that the only
um difference between the 2019
application and this the the actual
constructed building was the uh the
two-bedroom well sorry the three bedroom
two car parking spaces is that correct
in your view
back to the 2019 original application
that was passed we'll know because the
position of their house has changed it's
two meters further forward the roof
height has changed to accommodate the
extra bedrooms which I do think is
highly relevant
um and in order to access them there's a
reported um staircase as well so it's
about the fact it was changed from a
three-bed cottage application to what
became five bedrooms and that structure
is still there
nature but the agent has stated now that
that is now cluster's attic space
well forgive me counselor Cargill but
on on track record I don't trust that
that is simply attic space
it's a very high attic
okay do we have any more questions of
our war member
um councilor Donald do you know if the
building has been occupied since it's
been built
I can't answer that question I'm afraid
okay and you referred to the I think the
bushes and the trees at the front of the
form part of the village visibility
displays to be in the county council's
ownership are you absolutely sure that's
County Council and not neighboring
residents I just want to be clear I'm
not criticizing anything I just want my
understanding from discussion with both
Parish Council and looking at
correspondence with
um WCC it was our understanding that it
was WCC but you can seek further
clarification on that my understanding
was it is WCC which is why we're
concerned about timely trimmings it's
your understanding ours after thank you
very much it doesn't appear there are
going to be any more questions so
canceled on thank you very much for your
time contributions
okay let's move to points of
clarification I'm assume there's going
to be a few counter off
um
yes so uh point of clarifications so if
if we as committee were to Grant this
um what is to
um to prevent the applicant going for
permitted development and reinstating
the Upper Floor
glad you asked counselor my condition
uh recommended condition
11. in the report which removes
permitted development rights for uh
extensions Dormers Roof lights and
porches that's classes one a two part
sorry part one class is a to d in the
general Community Development order the
effect of that is they won't be anybody
attempting to put a bedroom in the roof
space would have to submit a planning
application to be determined on its own
merits before they could put in any roof
lights so it would be pretty dark before
they could add a dormer so that you know
they could see out
um also before they put a bedroom on the
ground floor in an extension for example
or all of these things basically would
increase the parking space requirement
which is why we don't want to do that so
they they can't provide three spaces so
we want to stop that equally we don't
want any development forward of the
principal elevation because that would
reduce the space available to parking as
it is so remove the right supporters as
well any of those developments will
therefore have to come in for a planning
application we we would look at that and
given the justification for it
I'll leave it at that I think given the
justification for it it would be a
fairly obvious decision for the case
officer
if I may just follow on from that before
I bring in other members that have
signaled um am I writing thinking that
notwithstanding the fact that the roof
height is is higher and the front
elevation is closer to the road
um one once permission has been granted
and and a property built internal
changes are entirely open to the
individual owners and occupiers to do so
in theory that attic space could be
turned into rooms
um it's but by removing permissive
development what we're basically doing
is preventing any natural light to get
in there short of having a full
application is that a fair assessment
that's correct chair yeah we can't
directly control what people do what
what sort of works people do within
their houses because it's not
development it's not it's not an active
development that requires planning
permission so it doesn't come anywhere
near us what we can do is do it
indirectly with this condition thank you
very much Council Adam please
a relative say well can I see the photos
real quick please and related to that is
um slow confused over the definition
that has been given in terms of removing
the roof lights and tiling over the roof
lights is the roof light structure still
in situ or
so that you can see you can see one roof
like that um if we just flip back to the
plan for a second you can see that that
reflight is there that serves an ensuite
bathroom
uh which is here it's on the first floor
so the other roof lights that were here
which in this photo would be there and
the other side
um they they've been removed I I should
stress that I haven't been into the roof
space I haven't I can't see what's in
there for myself but I've looked at it
from the outside they're certainly not
there on the outside
I just do you mind just leaving the
front elevation photo up
yeah
great thank you Council Harvey
yes thank you
um there's clearly an immense amount of
frustration and dissatisfaction with
what's going on can I ask the officer
and I hope this is not being too
pedestrian could I ask the officer in
relation to the description of
development could he go through line by
line and give a thumbnail so sketch of
what the question is that we are being
asked to what the variation is in
practice that we're being asked to agree
to and could he also confirm or not that
if we
um
if we find that we we can't accept or we
don't want don't wish to accept one or
more conditions is this All or Nothing
this is an application where if one leg
Falls it all falls
or do we have to agree one word that
rejects or accept all the variations but
I'm I'm most Keen that members of the
committee absolutely do understand what
variation is being asked for
uh certainly um probably
uh easiest to sort of illustrate it with
the the plans whilst The Talk
so
this is the Baseline you've heard
earlier applications mentioned they they
were withdrawn the this is the Baseline
this is what the we're comparing the
current application to so the important
parts on this on this picture basically
are the Heights
um and the window Arrangement again if
we flick on
you can see I've circled everything
that's a change basically and the height
has changed here in the bottom left
um which is to say the chimney has
become shorter and the ridge Heights of
the remaining two of the larger and
smaller Ridge have increased
um
then we have this external chimney
breast that was previously
that's the same elevation that was
previously internal
we have
two bedrooms in the roof space they're
no longer there so ignore that
the roof lights no longer there ignore
that so
this is what we're looking at now
compared to
the first application
5.3 meters is the distance there it's
now 3.6 meters so let's move closer to
the road the Hedge has also moved
slightly closer to the road
um but that's that's change number one
it's close to the road
change them to external chimney breast
there's some windows that are in
different places nobody's interested in
those nobody's maybe subjected to those
they don't cause any issues
and that's it so it's the Hat it's the
Heights and the distance to the road
basically that is those are now the
changes
um
an external chili breast I suppose is
also called some common external trim
your breasts distance between house and
Road and uh Heights roof Heights thank
you
marvelous thank you very much
um anyone else how many points of
clarification Council roll
uh yeah so
breast
uh obviously it wasn't on the original
application
um
what's your view on that is it is it is
it something that is in keeping with
with the village
is it do we have
um do we have can we demonstrate that
elsewhere in the village that there are
external chimney breasts
yeah it's it's not something that I've
picked up on as being a particular
priority in the parish plan or any other
um sort of local policy
um there are other external chimneys
elsewhere furthermore it's kind of
tucked away around the side it's not
really visible in the streets okay
cancer Adam
uh very quickly I the plans that you've
got up are you saying that these are the
most recent ones submitted that are
meant to reflect as build
the the plan on screen now is is that
yeah yes counselor um whether it does or
not it's a matter of enforcement rather
than us because yeah that was my
follow-on because the photos seem to
differ slightly but if it's an
enforcement natural
any more for any more I've got one
um obviously you went on site visits
today I made certain observations
there's one in particular I want to
check before we move forward if we're
Minister Grant
um would we be able to put onto the I
see you've got a visitor visibility
display condition would be able to
extend that to say that those visibility
splays need to be met before occupation
or in if it's already been occupied no
later than three months from the date of
permission
uh yeah in my view uh chair yeah um it
would be useful to know for sure whether
it has been occupied because if if it
has hasn't been occupied then we could
just use the existing condition if not
then yes the timed trigger would be
would be possible okay I've just been
observing again outside out here and and
I can see the agent is shaking the head
and saying no it has not been occupied
and that's just been confirmed again so
I think if we're minded to that I think
we should consider that
um
Council Ralph
you're going to ruin the day I ever
subbed on this committee aren't you
um
so um if this if this committee were
minded to object to this application
uh can I it's a question I asked um
councilor Donald but can you answer can
you answer that is Is it feasible the
roof can be reduced in height is it
feasible I mean clearly it's not
feasible the entire building can move
back to the original position but Is it
feasible the roof can be reduced in
height I'll answer that question yes
I our enforcement have the ability and
facility to be able to enforce what has
been approved what has been approved is
not what is there now and they will take
it through the appropriate process okay
so so further on so can they can they
also enforce repositioning of the
building yes of course they can it's
within approved plans thank you
okay I think we can move to debate now
who would like to kick us off councilor
Kendall thank you chairman I think
Council Rolf has really helped me out at
the end
the question is and I didn't
ask ask your Imports clarification
the question that she's been sticking on
my mind which is what if we refuse well
absolutely you're quite right
um we we're empowered to you know go
through enforcement and to
that means demolish that means demolish
but what will happen before we get to
that stage is the applicant will appeal
the entire application go to an
inspector who will look at this and say
is it justifiable to make these people
tear down the building move it back to
where it was is it justifiable to take
the roof light down I'm sorry but I just
don't think the inspector will do that
the inspector will look at what's there
and come to pretty much exactly the same
conclusion that our officer has which is
it ain't great there have been lots of
mistakes along the way and it's really
not fair to the residents of of Pilgrim
priors but
he will eventually he or she will
eventually go for it so with that in
mind
I'm going to propose we Grant
Council Harvey
I'm going to put the exact opposite
point of view
because
um
there is
there is clearly frustration and anger
amongst local people that what had been
a first of all the the decision was
narrow in the first place fine it was
made and that's what you have to go with
that's fine
uh the application was granted on the
basis that a certain building would be
built in a certain position with certain
facilities
and I I would rather we reviewed this
application and if the applicant wants
to take it to appeal take it to appeal
because there are times when you put a
stake in the ground and you you vote for
what you really believe in and I really
believe
in this application being with the the
application that was originally approved
is what was approved what is there now
is not what was approved and if the if
it means demolition
that's fine by me the the issue for me
is uh so strong that I would I don't
normally willingly provoke an appeal but
for me this is one of those instances
where we have got to stand on the basis
of what was approved this this this
offends
um the policy it offends a lot of people
who are fair-minded reasonable people
and for me I am strongly of the view
that this is one for once that we should
not accept the officer's recommendation
um
even though I suspect he would argue
that it's well it will argue for me this
is one that needs to go to appeal if
necessary councilor Harvey can I assume
that you are making a proposal to refuse
I think you're better I'm going to
accept that so I'm going to set that as
your formal proposal to refuse what I am
going to ask you to do so don't
necessarily disagree with what a lot of
a lot of what you've said however I
haven't heard any planning reasons to
why as to why you're refusing it so I
need you to think about those we will
continue to have the rest of the debate
while you come to that and then we will
come back to you should we need to
councilor Curtis please
thank you I'm not necessarily me yet
um seconding the the proposal but
I do agree with a lot of the sentiment
about what has been said and I think you
know you don't accidentally build a
house two meters forward from where
you've been given planning permission
you know these these aren't accidents
these are deliberate
um
choices that the developer makes and if
they make those deliberate choices to
flout the planning permission that's
been given then I think they should the
you know there will be consequences and
I I think perhaps too often we air
on this committee on this on the side of
oh well you know it's only a meter here
it's only a meter there it's only a
minor infringement here it's only a
minor infringement there
um so yes I'm not yet seconding but I am
minded
um
I'm going to take slime Bridge with what
you the last part of what you just said
um only a meter here only meter there
um my view of the committee and the way
we make decisions is based on what's put
in front of us
um the way
retrospective planning applications will
wind me up beyond belief and that is why
I fully support the sentiment of
councilor Harvey's uh what councilor
Harvey had to say having said that there
is a planning law and plan and a process
in which we go down that allows for
retrospective planning applications such
as this we then in essence are viewing
it as a new application in its current
form so it's not a question of oh it's
only a meter here that's been added only
is that we're not going to do anything
about it it's a question of we've gone
through a process enforcement has been
taken an application has been invited an
application has come in we are now
considering the pros and cons and the
planning classes related to that item
you're it's within your gift to disagree
with the officer's recommendation but I
would err on the side of caution when we
say this committee looks at a meter here
or the meter there and dismisses it we
don't we follow proper process and that
has to be clear
yes I'm sorry
um I didn't mean to be at all pejorative
about the way this committee Works how I
just clarify that for all members here
thank you
Council Dixon please
thank you chairman
[Music]
reasons why we could refuse it if we are
so minded
situation whereby
looking at
the
footprint it's moved forward by two
meters
um impact of that
a shorter front garden and a longer Back
Garden
marginal I think and I don't think that
has has had any impact upon the
neighbors
obviously it has reduced copper in space
but then again as a three-bedroom
property which is what the application
is before us there is sufficient parking
available at the front now to meet that
requirement
so to my mind the only possible reason
we could give for refusal is the
increase in height and whether or not we
cons regard that as now being
overbearing
on number one
home stalls Meadow I think it is
um
and
a question for Paul
obviously the ridge has moved is the
pitch the same so are the is the as the
gutter also gone up by half a meter oh
the other walls still the original
height because it will have a slight
impact upon the uh the overbearingness
of that Gable wall
so the question if I can just check my
understanding is have has have the eaves
gone up as well as the ridge effectively
uh yes
Council form and I think you saw your
hand go up earlier is that right no
council please
all right so we are in the debate now
we're not asking yeah it just cut the
things up I'm sorry I will get the point
eventually
um
I'm just going to refer to councilor
um
brain's got cats that have is um
my eyes are tired eyes are tired so
um
just because the decision is narrow it
doesn't dilute it's legitimacy and we've
had two narrow planning decisions
tonight six five and went in the
planning balance and I disagree with
them but I fully accept those decisions
yeah of course we went through the
process and did it uh discussed it
properly
and I'm sometimes concerned about the
language that was used you know Cancer's
opportunity to ensure residents are are
aware what a planning application covers
and what a planning committee does
and I'm happy for us to protect red clay
legislate and if necessary prosecute or
enforce where it's reasonable and legal
to do so but I don't like to hear the
word punish at this committee and if
that was the slip of the tongue I'm
happy to accept that protect that's fine
but I don't think we should be using the
word punish at this committee
so so that oh yeah I've got that off my
chest I'm happy to do that and I will
stick by you know that comment you know
three thick and thin
but certainly this is a difficult one
and I can understand this I think this
will be a close close vote
um it's all down to reasonableness and
again I I'm on the same road as
councilor Kendall is this reasonable to
do so
and are we going down the route of a
planning appeal uh where the planning
inspector will consider all the facts as
well and it might be the right thing to
do to go to a plan in the inspector
appeal because of everything will be
will be discussed in the open so I will
be supporting councilor candles can I
just confirm that is that a seconding of
cancer okay thank you very much
councilor Adam please thank you um
tell me the councilor Kendall said so in
in elaborator on where this process
might go made me think about the other
one thing that sort of I've touched on
I think from what I can see that the
plans and drawings we have in front of
us don't reflect what's actually been
built which means that even if they at
least from what I can see
which seems to be
um confirmed by you saying that the
eaves have gone up as well because I
think that's what I've seen the photos
which would suggest that if we did
approve it as they are position on the
site may be acceptable but I think they
still have to bring the roof down under
enforcement and we'd have
one would have good cause to involve
enforcement within that
now broadly speaking I'm in I'm in
agreement with councilor Harvey and I'm
looking forward to hearing his reasons
for his proposal but my thought is that
if it were approved
find the positions moved and we might
not all like that but I still think
enforcement action would likely be a
forthcoming that's me projecting on my
thoughts and may not be relevant
planning but
that it's certainly food for thought I'd
say on on this and I'd welcome some
input from the officers just to confirm
whether they think they are might be the
case as well
um
I'm looking forward to a drink after
this
I don't know how much of that anyone got
so I I'm throwing enough to start again
um what we're looking at the plans that
are in front of us and are being
considered by us now are what's been
built what is on the site
where the confusion I think will
probably have come is that we are
looking at the previous application
what had been done and what has now been
put in place it gets very confusing so I
if we are minded to approve tonight I
don't think there'll be any form of
enforcement afterwards because that
includes the right changing the ridge
height and the eve height and also the
movement forward
so I don't think we need to worry too
much about that
um before you come in Council off I'm
very conscious of the fact that it's now
10 to 10. we have gone on way too long I
want to bring this to a conclusion as
soon as possible let me tell you what I
observed on site today from the
neighboring Garden
the garden and forgive me for the
gentleman Whose Garden it is is not
desperately long it's not desperately
short but it's not desperately long
any form of development behind the
Hedgerow is going to be okay he's going
to have a negative impact
the question I'm wrestling with is is
that additional I think we've said at
half a meter
going to have a significant overbearing
impact over that being half a meter
lower
that is what I'm trying to wrestle with
in my mind
I'm also very conscious of the fact that
the exit onto that Main Road whilst the
visibility splay can be achieved what I
observed today was it's achieved to the
left as you're exiting but is not
achieved to the right without
significant hedge cutting and or removal
it's something to be mindful of now
we've been told by our war member that
is in the ownership of WCC Works County
Council Works County Council have not
provided an objection
so we can reasonably assume that they
will create enough
thank you
one of these things is gonna get thrown
in a minute
no I'm still speaking if it's relevant
after I've finished then I'll ask you
the one I observed as I said was the the
fact what I understood from
conversations
um and questions that I asked today is
that their Hedgerow and the fencing is
not in the ownership of watch County
Council but is in fact in the ownership
of the neighboring property
so we need to be mindful of that that I
understand that neighboring property is
objecting so whether those visibility
splays can be achieved or not is it in
question if we're minded to Grant
and I'm going to ask the proposal in a
second day uh to add this I think we
must have a condition that says the
visibility splays need to be achieved
before occupation
I.E those bushes and trees need to be
removed
that's my view
um I will leave it open to you
um given we have had a proposal and
we're going to move to a vote on that
now we have had a proposal to Grant and
it has been seconded are you happy for
that visibility display condition to be
added
yes are you happy as well good thank you
I'm so
I've tried to be as
gentle and welcoming to everyone as I
possibly can today I'm not accusing you
guys of causing problems we've had
people shouting out earlier on we are
trying to conduct business and we're
going to try and conduct business
properly I told you I'd come back to you
when we were done I wasn't done shouting
is not going to help
councilor O'Donnell you have an
opportunity to come back for a point of
fact if you'd like to come to the front
here and speak into the microphone and
give us that point of fact that would be
helpful
foreign
I think the reason they were shouting
out is because this is relevant to your
um
explanation just then it's my error the
Hedge is not watch County Council it's
actually one of the residents at the
back that's why he was shouting out is
Mark's hedge that he would not be
prepared to move his advised I think I'd
already said that so whether it's a
civil matter as to whether or not uh the
resident wants his fence removed as I
said what I want to have in here is a
condition if we're minus a grant is a
condition that says visibility space
must be achieved before occupation if
that requires the resident's fences to
be cut down or Hedges to be cut down
that is a civil matter between him and
the owners of this land it is not a
condition or a consideration for this
planning committee
okay just for clarification he's not
going to remove it so there won't be
even a discussion line for him
that's not relevant to the planning
committee
councilor Curtis if you've got something
please be quick because it is now nearly
10 o'clock and we need to make a
decision
just to clarify then that it seems from
what council O'Donnell has said that the
visibility slaves cannot be achieved
because that if the visibility space
cannot be achieved the property cannot
be occupied and enforcement action will
be taken
and obviously that is the discretion of
the enforcement team but action they
will have to go through their relevant
process
right
I think we've done it to death
can we please move forward with a vote
The Proposal is to Grant in line with
the officer requirement
sorry very quick are we going to move
permitted development rights it's a
condition on the
report yes
The Proposal is to Grant in line with
the office recommendation with the
addition of the visibility displays
being achieved prior to occupation
could I please have a show of hands for
those in favor of granting
one two three four five six seven and
against
one two and abstentions two committee
therefore resolves a Grant application
2200-4748 very
and I was offer recommendation and with
the additional conditions
okay
members while the members of the public
are leaving
um we do have one final item to go
through um and I do given we're here and
we've taken a vote to continue
unconscious it's 10 o'clock let's just
get on with it
application reference 2201984 ful that
is 47 Legend Road in stratford-upon-avon
our presenting officer is Paul Thompson
foreign
application in Stratford the only reason
we're here looking at it is because it's
to cancel employees is the applicant uh
we have one uh objection just talking
about
um as you see yeah reconservatory fairly
standard issue uh one objection just a
bit worried about construction traffic
blocking his driveway
which is a
there that's a standard construction
issue no other objections no other
concerns raised by the case officer
that's what it looks like over to you
Paul thank you very much we have no
speakers on this item uh do we have any
points of clarification no
um can I propose that we Grant in line
with office recommendations
in favor of granting unanimous thank you
very much is there any open business in
that case members thank you very much I
know it's been late
thank you for your time officers
especially and particularly are covered
patients thank you for your time as well
and we'll see in a couple of weeks thank
you chair thanks so nice to see you